GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR HEARING US THIS MORNING MY
NAME IS TIED DAVID I IN THE
RIGHT I MEAN IF YOU STOP FOR
JUST A MAJORITY AUDIO IS NOT
WORKING- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET YOUR TESTIMONY SO OTHER
PEOPLE CAN HEAR IT BESIDES US
I'M GONNA BE WE WAS AT THE SAME
FOR ME NO I THINK I CAN HEAR
YOURS I WAS IN THE WAY BETTER
THE SECOND MAYBE I CAN'T. I
THINK MAYBE YOU'RE- YOUR SOUND
LIKE YOU'RE ON. THE PREFERRED.
YES YEAH. THE REST OF THE-
PRACTICE. ARE WE GET. NOW WE'RE
GOOD. ALL RIGHT. OR ANY
PROCEEDING. I THINK KILLED. A
GOOD MORNING. I ANTI DAVID.
EXACT ADDRESS. OF THE HOUSE.
ACTION CO- ARE PROUD SPONSORS
OF. AB TWENTY SIXTY THREE. AS
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL WHERE THE
STATE TEST THE BONUS. IS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO CREATE HOUSING.
AT ALL LEVELS OF AFFORDABILITY.
THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE. OF THE
STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW. WAS TO
INCENTIVIZE. ON SITE. AFFORDABLE
UNITS. IN EXCHANGE. FOR THOSE ON
SITE UNITS. ARM DEVELOPERS ARE
DEVELOPMENTS WERE- GRANTED.
BONUS UNITS. THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE. ARMED MARKET RATE. AN
UNENCUMBERED. A SOME UNITS. ARE
CIRCUMVENTING THE SPIRIT OF THE
STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW BY
CHARGING AFFORDABLE HOUSING FEES
ON THE STATE DENSITY BONUS UNITS
. CIRCUMVENTING THE SPIRIT OF
THE STATE DENSITY BONUS LAW BY
CHARGING FEES HAS A REAL WORLD%
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR
EXAMPLE IN MY HOMETOWN OF SAN
FRANCISCO OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IMPOSED IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FATE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ON BONUS UNITS.
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAVE
INDEPENDENTLY FOUND AND VERIFIED
THE URBAN FORTY TWO PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN ENTITLED UNDER
THE STATE DENSITY BONUS AND SAN
FRANCISCO BUT NOT ONE OF THOSE
UNITS HAVE PAID THE FIFTY.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THOSE FORTY
TWO PROJECTS ONLY TO HAVE
STARTED CONSTRUCTION ONE IS A
100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
THAT IS EXEMPT FROM THE FEE THE
OTHER PROJECT WAS GRANDFATHERED
IN IT WOULD NOT ENTITLE BEFORE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO
OF THE V. FORTY REMAINING
PROJECTS THAT REPRESENTS ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND UNITS OF HOUSING
OF WHICH SEVEN HUNDRED OF THOSE
UNITS WILL BE PERMANENTLY
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE. AND THAT
THESE FEES ARE COST UP TO TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DOOR. SO I
WAS SPEAKING TO A DEVELOPER
YESTERDAY WHO IS ONE OF THE
PROJECT IS ALL OF A TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY UNIT PROJECT THAT HAS
BEEN ENTITLED THAT HAS A FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR. IN
LIEU FEE FROM THE FROM THE BONUS
UNITS AND THAT PROJECT IS NOT
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE OF THOSE
FEES. SO TO ME THIS SEEMS LIKE A
LOSE LOSE PROPOSITION. THAT THIS
FEES BEEN PUT IN PLACE AT ZERO
DOLLARS A BEEN COLLECTED. AND
THERE ARE FOUR THOUSAND UNITS OF
MIXED INCOME HOUSING THAT IS NOT
NEW FORD. OF WHICH SEVEN HUNDRED
AGAIN OF THOSE UNITS IS PARTLY
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE. SO TO ME
THIS SEEMS LIKE A POLICY LOSS ON
BOTH ENDS. SO YOU KNOW IN IT-
INCLUSION THIS BILL WILL UNLOCK
MIXED INCOME HOUSING IN MY
HOMETOWN AND SIMULTANEOUSLY
ENSURE THAT OTHER MUNICIPALITIES
DO NOT ADOPT EQUALLY HARMFUL
POLICIES AIMED AT UNDERMINING
STATE TENCENT STATE DENSITY
BONUS LAW. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. SURE
YES. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS BEATRICE
GARDEN S. DUNCAN. I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT IT TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY SIXTY THREE I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER I HEALTH AND
WELLNESS ADVOCATE I'M A LEUKEMIA
PATIENT I'M ALSO A MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. WHO IS NO LONGER
ABLE TO LIVE IN THE SAME CITY AS
MY CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
DUE TO THAT THEY AREAS HOUSING
SHORTAGE DISPLACEMENT AND
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. MY HUSBAND
AND I MARRIED REYES STAR KIDS IN
WELCOME MY GRANDKIDS WHILE
RENTING IN SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE THE WESTERN
ADDITION INGLESIDE. AND BAYVIEW
. BOTH LONGTIME MEMBERS OF SEIU
MY HUSBAND AND I DEVOTED OUR
CAREERS TO WORKING IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. IN CITY GOVERNMENT AND
WITH LOCAL NONPROFITS. BUT AFTER
LIVING IN THE CITY FOR MORE THAN
FORTY YEARS WE BECAME PRICED OUT
OF THE VERY DUBBED OUT AT THAT
STAGE T THE VERY TIME WHEN WE
NEEDED TO BE CLOSER CLOSEST TO
OUR CHILDREN. GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. NOW WIDOW.
I'M LIVING IN SAN LEANDRO I WISH
I COULD AFFORD TO LIVE NEAR MY
FAMILY BUT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE DUE
TO THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. MY STORY IS. IS ONE OF
THEM TO COME IN FOR FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IT IS
SHAMEFUL THAT SENIOR CITIZENS
ARE GETTING PUSHED OUT OF OTHER
COME OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OUR CITIES HAVE FAILED
TO BUILD ENOUGH HOUSING FOR
RESIDENTS OF ALL INCOME LEVELS.
OUR LEADERS SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO MAKE IT
FASTER AND EASIER BUT MORE
AFFORDABLE TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE ASSESSABLE
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE. IN OUR
FAMILIES CAN REMAIN TOGETHER. AB
TWENTY SIXTY THREE IS KEY TO
THIS GOAL. AS A WOULD HELP
ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO CREATING
MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES THAT
RESIDENTS WILL DEFINITELY NEED.
FOR THIS REASON I'M HERE TO
SPEAK IN FRONT OF THIS MARVELOUS
COMMITTEE AN IMPORTANT COMMITTEE
AND NOT PER SHOULD DECIDE TO
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LISTENING TO ME AND I TRULY
APPRECIATE AND ASK FOR THE FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS MARVELOUS AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE ROOM AND IF THERE'S- WITH TO
SPEAK IN OF IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL ARE LET LET US KNOW THAT
YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL-
WHEN YOU COME UP AND- SPEAK.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR- I
FULLY FOR MANY DAYS IS THAT
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
CIVIC WELL THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SPUR. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CORY SMITH SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE CALIFORNIA YIMBY
CIRCULATE SAN DIEGO. THE SPACE
ON DEMOCRATS GREENBELT ALLIANCE
MEETING H. CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PENINSULA FOR EVERYONE. PEOPLE
FOR HOUSING ORANGE COUNTY THE
SOUTH PASADENA RESIDENTS FOR
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION THE TWO HUNDRED AND
YOU'LL BE ACTION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GREAT DOESN'T THERE'S
ANYBODY ALSO EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE-WE'RE GONNA GO TO PHONE LINES
ARE WE DO NOT HAVE THAT OKAY SO
THERE IS NO PHONE LINES. SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS. GO TO
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED.
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
THAT WE CHOOSE TO MAKE
THEMSELVES HEARD. THEY'RE BEING
DONE WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS. IT'S
QUIRK-SILVA I REPORT THIS BILL I
A- REALLY THINK THESE THIS TYPE
OF LEGISLATION IS GOING TO BE
OUR PATHWAY TO GET THOSE SEVEN
HUNDRED UNITS THOUSAND UNITS AND
IF WE CONTINUE TO DO THIS KIND
OF LEGISLATION WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO OUR GOAL BUT THANK YOU
FOR SAYING THAT WERE MARVELOUS
BECAUSE WE NEVER HEAR THAT. AND
YOU SAID IT TWICE. THANK YOU
MASON WAS IT IS MR WARD THANK
YOU ALSO. WE ON. RIYAN YEAH OKAY
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE ABLE
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT- THESE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE HAVING
THROUGH- DOES DENSITY PROGRAMS
ARE NOT- BEING- I THINK A LOT
WATER DOWN- WITH A LOT OF THE
OTHER SEEM I'M CONDITIONS AND
FEES THAT ARE PUT OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW SO IT MAKES ALL THE
SENSE IN THE WORLD TO ME I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK.
AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT. I'M HAPPY
TO BE SUPPORTER TODAY THANK YOU.
YOU AND I WILL CHIME IN WITH
THAT MY SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS- THAT-
COMMUNITIES HAVE A LOT OF TIMES
THE WHEN IT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE FEES THAT ARE GENERATED-
THIS FEES ARE ACTUALLY SOME OF
THEM HAVE TO HAVE AN ACCESS TO
WHAT IS BEING DONE. AND THEIR
NEXUS IS USUALLY A UNIT BECAUSE
THAT UNIT HAS A HOUSE A PERSON
THAT WORKS AND MAYBE A COUPLE OF
KIDS WITH IT AND THOSE HAVE
IMPACTS ON THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE IMPACTS ARE SPREAD AMONGST
HOWEVER MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE. IN THAT COMMUNITY SO WHEN
THERE'S A SURGE IN THE IMPACTS-
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE THEY GET
THOSE NUMBERS FROM I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S SUPER INTENTIONAL TO
MAKE IT CERTAINLY NOT TO MAKE
MONEY- IT'S SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE AMENITIES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THAT BETTER BENEFIT
EVERYBODY AND- BUT THAT BEING
SAID- WHEN THEY DO THEIR GENERAL
PLAN WITHOUT THE DENSITY BONUS
THOSE ARE FACTORED IN SO I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD COMPROMISE AND
BEING ABLE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SO WHEN A APPROPRIATE TIME COMES
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING AND-
WILL. PUT IT ON HOLD UNTIL WE
GET ENOUGH OF THANK YOU MISTER
RIGHT I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS THANKS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MS REYES. YOU'RE
IN THE YES WE ARE. I GUESS.
YEAH MISTER REYES HAD A SPECIAL
REQUEST MS BOERNER HORVATH ARE
YOU OKAY WITH THAT DAY TO COME
UP AND GIVE HER. I THANK YOU. AB
TWO TWO ONE SEVEN. MIND YOU THIS
IS STILL. WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN THE
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
PRODUCTION ACT WHICH WILL
EMPOWER CALIFORNIA FAMILIES TO
BECOME FIRST TIME HOMEOWNERS.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUTATIVITY
LAMENT TO INCREASE THE PER UNIT
AND TOTAL PROJECT CAPS. WITHIN
THE CAL HOME PROGRAM BASED ON
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT COSTS WHICH
WILL ENCOURAGE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOMES. WE KNOW
THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP IS PROVEN TO
HELP FAMILIES BUILD GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND ACHIEVE FINANCIAL
STABILITY. YET HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA REMAINS GROSSLY
INEQUITABLE ONLY 41% OF BLACKS
AND 49% OF LATINO FAMILIES OWNED
THEIR HOMES COMPARED 268% OF
WHITE AND SIXTY SIX PERCENT. OF
ASIAN FAMILIES. THE CALHOUN
PROGRAM WAS PUSHED TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BY PROVIDING GRANTS
TO LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT CORPORATIONS TO
CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROMOTE FIRST TIME HOME
OWNERSHIP. CURRENTLY THE CALHOUN
PROGRAM WAS OVER SUBSCRIBED AND
UNDERFUNDED WHICH HAS SEVERELY
LIMITED THE ABILITY OF NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS TO ACCESS THESE
FUNDS. THIS MEANS THAT
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOMES HAVE GONE UNBUILT YEAR
AFTER YEAR. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN WILL ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES BY PERMITTING H. C. D. TO
INCREASE PER UNIT AND TOTAL
PROJECT ALLOCATIONS WITHIN THE
CAL HOME PROGRAMS BASED ON LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT COSTS. THIS BILL
WHEN SHE WILL ENSURE THESE CAPS
ARE UPDATED REGULARLY BY
REQUIRING H. C. D. TO CONSIDER
INCREASING ALLOCATIONS FOR EACH
NEW ROUND OF FUNDING. BY
UPDATING THE FUNDING CAP FOR CAL
HOME AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
WILL PROMOTE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND GENERATE
MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES TO BECOME FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS THAT B. OUR
ACCOUNT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
. THANK YOU GO AHEAD THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE I'M WRKO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
REPRESENTING ALL OF OUR
AFFILIATES STATEWIDE IN RURAL
AND URBAN AREAS THROUGHOUT. HOW
TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE DEED RESTRICTED
HOME OWNERSHIP UNITS BY UPDATING
THE OUTDATED AND THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH TO THE PER
UNIT AND PER PROJECT FUNDING
CAPS THIS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
MAKE INCREASES. AS APPROPRIATE
BASED ON THE ACTUAL DEVELOPMENT
COSTS NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE.
TO RUN OUT WITH NO PLANS TO
REPLACE IT. HABITAT THROUGH
HABITAT AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN ACCESSING IS FINDING AND
PRODUCING MORE OWNERSHIP UNITS
IN RURAL AND IN METROPOLITAN
AREAS ALL THE WAY FROM SAN DIEGO
THROUGH NEVADA COUNTY. BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONSIDER SETTING THE HIGHER
UPPER LIMIT CAPS BASED ON COST
THIS WILL BE MORE EQUITABLE TO
INCREASING THE SUPPLY FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA'S COSTLY
PERIOD BUT SOME AREAS ARE EVEN
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN OTHERS BY
HAVING THE SAME EXACT FUNDING
CAP REGARDLESS OF COST. THIS
CREATES A GREATER BURDEN WHERE
THE DEVELOPMENT COSTS ARE HIGHER
THE CURRENT CAP IS HUNDRED
THOUSAND SO THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY
ASSIST WITH MAYBE FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY PERCENT. OF AN AFFORDABLE
UNIT IN OAKLAND OR SAN DIEGO BUT
THAT MIGHT MAKE UP CLOSER TO FOR
PER. OF AN AFFORDABLE UNIT IN
SOMEWHERE LIKE CHICO OR TULARE
COUNTY BY RAISING THE CAP
ALLOWING EACH REGION CAN ACCESS
AN AMOUNT THAT IS MOST
APPROPRIATE IN RELATION TO THEIR
COST. HABITAT IS EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE AT LEVERAGING THE
STATE FUNDING WITH PRIVATE
DOLLARS AND INCREASING THE CAP
WILL HELP US ACCELERATE
PRODUCTION IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY BUILDS HIGHER DENSITY
MULTI FAMILY MULTI LEVEL HOMES
AS WELL AS SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
THIS LEGISLATION IS KEY TO
INCREASING HOMEOWNERSHIP SUPPLY
AND FOR THESE REASONS. AND A
CALIFORNIA COMMENCE TWENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU HI THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND AT THIS
TIME IF THERE IS ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK ON
FAVOR OF THE BILL. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR GOOD
MORNING GENESIS TODAY ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU IT
APPEARS WE JUST HAVE THE ONE
SPEAKER SO WE'LL GO AHEAD IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION ON FILE
SO THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION OF WE'VE COME UP
TO THE MIKE AND STATE SO.
DOESN'T APPEAR ANYBODY'S SO
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE AUTHOR. NO QUESTIONS ARE
I KNOW THE COSTS HAVE GONE UP
AND SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE. OFFERING THE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT WE'RE NOT
DECREASING OUR PRODUCTIVITY OUR
UNITS ARE ABLE TO PRODUCE OUT
THERE- HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTER
TODAY AND AS THIS MOVE FOR YOU
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT A
FACTORED TO BUILD IN THERE THAT
MIGHT JUST BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE
THIS SO DOES REQUIRE SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION FIVE OR- TEN YEARS
FROM NOW BUT- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY WERE CONTINUING TO.
ASSIST EVEN MORE UNITS EVEN MORE
FAMILIES AS TIME GOES ON THANK
YOU. THIS QUIRK-SILVA. I HAVE A
- JUST WITH THE HABITAT- MODEL.
I KNOW THAT- AND I'VE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY IN MY CITIES TO
BRING FORWARD MODELS. BUT ON THE
UP FOR SALE PART AFTER THE
HOMEOWNER HAS- MOVED INTO A HOME
WHERE OWNERSHIP CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THAT. IN IS THAT ONLY YOUR MODEL
OR WILL IT BE PART OF THIS BILL.
YEAH I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER I
THINK YOU THE HABITAT MODEL
INCLUDES A FIRST AT FIRST RIGHT
OF REFUSAL SO THE HOMES ARE DEED
RESTRICTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S KEPT IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FULLBUT IF A HOMEOWNER.
CHOOSES TO SELL THEIR HOME AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY HAS FIRST RIGHT
EVERY PURCHASE SO THAT WE CAN
THEN SELL THAT TO ANOTHER LOW
INCOME QUALIFIED FAMILY- IS FAR
AS THIS BILL- IT DOES INCLUDE
THE DEED RESTRICTED BUT IT WOULD
BE UP TO EACH DEVELOPER TO HAVE
THEIR OWN CONDITIONS AROUND
THAT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IF
THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
THEN- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING WE'RE
STILL OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SO ONCE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WILL WILL
VOTE ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THIS BOERNER HORVATH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THIS MORNING
APPRECIATE IT. STILL OPERATING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE. SO YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU READY
THANK A GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL BUT ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR HER WORK ON THIS BILL-
THIS IS AN OFFICE SPONSORED BILL
AND THAT WE HAVE WORKED HARD TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE HOPEFULLY
WILL BE ABLE AND THE SUBSEQUENT
COMMITTEE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THE ADOPTION OF
MANDATORY BUILDING STANDARDS FOR
THE INSTALLATION OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS AN
EXISTING MULTI FAMILY DWELLINGS
SCHOOLS HOTELS AND MOTELS AND
NON RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
DURING RETROFITS TO EXISTING
BUILDING SAID TO BE CLEAR THIS
IS NOT RETROFITTING.
AUTOMATICALLY THERE'S A TRIGGER
THAT WILL DO IT RIGHT JUST LIKE
WE HAVE A STORM WATER RETENTION
BASINS AND OTHER SUCH THINGS AND
LANDIS IT'S A VERY COMMON THING
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE PULLING UP A
PARKING LOT THEN PUTTING IN SOME
EVEY ARE CHARGING STATIONS- AND
SO FOR THE MORE THAT WHEN THE
ADDITIONS OR ALTERATIONS ARE
MADE TO EXISTING MULTI FAMILY-
DWELLINGS HOTELS OR MOTELS AT
LEAST 25% OF SPACES MUST BE EASY
READY. MEANING THAT THE PARKING
SPACES HAVE BOTH THE RACEWAY AND
LOWER POWER LEVEL TWO ELECTRICAL
OUTLETS. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHEN WE SEE WE SEE THIS WITH
SOLAR YOU'VE SEEN THIS OF SOLAR
IF YOU'VE BEEN AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- YOU SEE THIS WITH
EV'S. IT DOESN'T HELP AND THE
BEST ANALOGY IS LIKE PUTTING IN
PLUMBING FOR TOILET BUT NOT
PUTTING IN THE TOILET DOESN'T
HELP YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM.
RIGHT SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS.
YOU KNOW BUILDING STANDARDS ARE
REQUIRING US TO PUT IN THE
PLUMBING FOR IT BUT NOT THE
FINAL CHARGER. AND SO WE'RE
DOING THE WIRING BUT NOT THIS-
THE FINAL THING YOU'RE NOT
GETTING TO THAT FINAL. IN POINT
AND IT'S LIKE OUR LAST MILE
PROBLEM WITH BROADBAND YOU SEE
THIS ACROSS THE BOARD SO WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO. IS
FIX THAT THAT PROBLEM HERE AND
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE EXPAND OUR
EASY FAST OR EVEN CHARGING
NETWORK ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
WERE BEING VERY INCLUSIVE AND
THAT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. WHO
LIVE IN MULTI FAMILY. RENTERS
ARE NOT LEFT OUT OF OUR OWN YOU
KNOW STRIVING FOR A MORE
SUSTAINABLE CALIFORNIA. WELL THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION UP
DOCTOR EASY CAPABLE AND EASY
READY REQUIREMENTS THE FOR
EXISTING BUILDINGS. IT DID NOT
INCLUDE EASY INSTALLED
REQUIREMENTS WHICH REQUIRE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. PLUS THE ACTUAL
CHARGING STATION ITSELF AND JUST
TO BE CLEAR THIS CHARGING
STATION DOESN'T NEED TO BE
OPERATED. BY THE MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENT OWNER IT COULD BE ONE
OF OUR MULTIPLE DELUDE OF
INNOVATIVE CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
THAT ARE DOING FASTER. DOING
CHARGING SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE THEM THEY CAN YOU KNOW. YOU
PARTNER WITH ANY NUMBER OF OUR
EVEY CHARGERS IN THE STATE IN
ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THIS. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE REGULATIONS TO BE
CONSIDERED ADOPTED TO FILL THIS
GAP. I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO MENTION THAT AS THE COST OF
EV'S. HAS DECREASED IN RECENT
YEARS AND IS EXPECTED TO
CONTINUE TO DECLINE IN THE
FUTURE. EV'S ARE BECOMING MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS HOWEVER THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO HOME CHARGING. REMAINS
THE MAJOR BARRIER TO EASY
OPTION. AND ALSO HEALTH ENERGY
COMMISSION FOUND THAT LOW INCOME
COMMITTEES WE HAVE FEWER EASY
CHARGING STATIONS PER CAPITA.
THE MIDDLE AND HIGH INCOME
COMMUNITIES RELIABLE ACCESS. TO
EASY CHARGING IS PARTICULARLY
CHAO J. FOR A- AND THOSE. IN
MOLD UNIT. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT MUCH AS 685% OF CHARGING.
FOR PERSONAL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
OCCURS AT HOME. BUT PEOPLE
LIVING IN APARTMENTS AND
CONDOMINIUMS. KNOWN AS MULTI
FAMILY BUILDINGS ARE MULTI UNIT
DWELLINGS. DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE CHARGING STATIONS. SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT TAKING AWAY LAYER
AFTER LAYER OF BARRIERS TO
ADOPTIONS OF THE VIS. YOU DO
HAVE THE COST OF THE CARS THAT
WE HAVE THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM AND WE NEED YOU MORE WE
NEEDED A SECONDARY CAR MARKET.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A WAY FOR RENTERS TO
CHARGE AT HOME. RENTERS ARE NOT
GOING TO BUY. AND WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE CREATING A STATE- CALL
CALIFORNIA REACHING OUR- CLIMATE
GOALS AND REALLY ADDRESSING THE
CLIMATE CRISIS FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE TO DO WHEN
THERE'S A HUGE EQUITY LENS.
AROUND IT AS WELL. SO AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY IT WOULD
PROVIDE GREATER MORE RELIABLE
ACCESS TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
FEES OF COLOR. SPECIFICALLY
THOSE LIVING IN MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS. WHICH MAKE A LECTURE
AND ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
OWNERSHIP. MORE FEASIBLE AND AS
A REMINDER I ALSO HAVE AS A
SEPARATE BILL AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY THREE AS A COMPANION TO
THE- THIS WILL CREATE A TAX
CREDIT OR ATTENDANCE. PROGRAMS
WORKING WITH THE REV AND TAX
COMMITTEE ON THIS- TO OFFSET THE
IMPACT TO MULTI FAMILY UNITS AND
LOW TO. MIDDLE INCOME.
NEIGHBORHOODS SO WE AREN'T BEING
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT. THIS IS THE
BILL THAT REQUIRES THE MANDATE
AND THEM BUT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO AMEND IT WITHOUT FUNDING AND
SO WE DO HAVE A SEPARATE BILL.
AND SOME POINT I AM. HOPING TO
GET THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
THROUGH- OUR HOUSE THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO JOIN THEM IN THE
SENATE. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES
BECAUSE I WITH THE BILL. HI
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANYBODY AND DO WE- GET
STATUS OF THEIR NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES- IN. SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. APPROACH THE
MIKE. NAME ORGANIZATION.
MICHELADA GONNA BE AFTER THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR AND WE ELS THERE BEING
NONE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES I
DON'T THINK THERE ARE. ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
TO THE MIKE. YES. THE MORNING
REX W. HIGH MONEY AVE A
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ICSE AND NAP CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS IT STANDS WE
ARE LOOKING FOR AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE DONE AND
GETTING SOME MINUTES AND BUT AS
AS IT STANDS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS COMING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND WE BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD GO TO THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION- THERE ARE
MANY ISSUES THAT THEY THEY TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THAT OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF PROCESS THAT
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH- THINGS LIKE
EVEN IF WE WERE TO TEAR UP AND
ALL THE COSTS THEY WOULD TAKE
THE TERRIBLE PARKING LOTS. THE
OLD GRADES THAT ARE THERE AND
EVEN TALKING TO SEND THE MUSE
UTILITIES SAY- EVEN IF YOU HAVE
THESE IN YOUR PARKING LOTS WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET YOU THE
ENERGY THAT WAS NECESSARILY ABLE
TO GET THESE THINGS UP AND
RUNNING SO AS OF NOW WE OPPOSE
WERE VERY LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND GETTING TO
A SPOT WHERE WE CAN BE OKAY ON
THIS BILL AND VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO THAT WAS THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION SEND OUT
WILL ADD JUST A NAME IS ASIAN
AND YOUR APP. ABSOLUTELY SILVIO
FOR OUR BEHALF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF- CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES. ASSOCIATION THANK
YOU SIR NEXT. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN CARS TEAR SOME OF THE
CAN. ASSIST SAYS IT. COLOR
ALLEGES. ACTION COMMITTEE
REPRESENTING THIRTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND OF OUR SUBSTATIONS
IN OPPOSTION. THANK YOU SIR
AND- AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE- MA'AM
SECRETARY. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
WEEKS THEY ARE HERE THEY ARE THE
CARILLO. GABRIELLE GABRIEL HERE
KALRA COLOR HERE KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA HERE WAR
WAR HERE WE HAVE A- RIGHT SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR KALRA SECOND
BY WARD TO BELIEVE OKAY- DO YOU
WANT TO CLOSE. OUR I'M SORRY WE
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS. SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THIS- I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT AND YOU ALREADY HAVE
ACCEPTED THOSE MANY THROUGH
THIS- COMMITTEE AS WELL THANK
YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE- THEY'RE
GONNA MAKE THIS FEASIBLE I
WONDER AND I WISH I. HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK YESTERDAY- THE
GOVERNOR IN A SIMILAR PROPOSAL
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND HAD
DIRECTED ECD- TO BE ABLE TO
START TO WORK ON SOME OF THE
SAME IMPROVEMENTS DO YOU HAVE
ANY- INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
HAVE. HAS BSE BEEN WORKING ON
THESE OR THEY DID AND WHAT THEY
DID IS THEY DID INTO EVM STOPPED
I THINK OF THE LEGISLATURE AS A
POLICY POSITION. AGAIN PUTTING
IN THE PLUMBING WITHOUT PUTTING
THE TOILET THAT MIGHT BE A
COMPROMISE THAT WORKS AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE DOING THE PAYING A
BILL THAT WOULD GIVE THE FUNDING
FOR IT BECAUSE I THINK THAT WAS
SOME OF THE ISSUES A LITTLE BIT
AROUND THE FUNDING. OF IT- YOU
KNOW AND SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A PROBLEM AS AS A LEGISLATURE
I SEE THIS AND WE SEE IT YOU
KNOW AND MY CITY WAS SOLAR ALL
THE TIME YOUR REQUIRE THAT THE
ALL NEW DEVELOPMENTS TO HAVE
SOLAR. CAPABLE BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE SOLAR PANELS SO THE
DEVELOPERS ARE TAKING ON THAT
COST ANYWAYS BUT IT'S NOT
TRANSLATING INTO THE
SUSTAINABILITY IS THAT WITH THAT
LAST BIT RIGHTS LAST MILE
PROBLEM THAT YOU HAVE ON OUR
SUSTAINABILITY AND SO THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU KIND
OF WORKING ON THE TECHNICAL
DETAIL HERE AS WELL AS A
COMPANION WORK FOR THE FUNDING
PART OF IT- THIS IS GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO REALLY
HELP US GET TO THAT NEXT LEAP-
THE EASY AVAILABILITY. AT A LOT
OF RESIDENCES AND SOME OTHER
PROPERTY SO- THE WORK CONTINUES
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION- ON SOME OTHER
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT'S NOT OUR
INTENTION- TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE
TRIGGER IS ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE TOOK. IS WHEN THEY'RE
ALREADY HAD TOP TOUCHING THE
PARKING ANY. THAT WOULD BE THE
TRIGGER FOR INSTALLING THE EV'S
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW AND I'M HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION IF
THERE'S MORE CLARIFICATION THAT
WE NEED TO DO. A GREAT ANY OTHER
AND THEN I'M GONNA TURN THE
CHAIR BACK OVER TO MISS WEEKS.
BUT THIS BILL IS COMPLICATED AS
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT AND I WILL JUST SAY
THAT I WILL SUPPORT IT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS
GOING FORWARD SO CAN YOU EXPLAIN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
PLANNING TO TAKE BECAUSE TOO
OFTEN IN COMMITTEES WE SAY WE
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO KIND OF A
CHANGE OF VOTE BUT I WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS- AND-
I UNDERSTAND I MEAN I HAVE TO
READ THEM BUT JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE NINE AMENDMENTS SO WE'RE
TAKING A LOT OF THE MOMENT SO
THE FIRST ONE- IS TO REFLECT THE
BILL'S PROVISION TO THAT EFFECT
EXISTING PARKING FACILITIES
RATHER THAN BUILDINGS DIRECTLY
SO THAT'S THE- THAT WHEN THEY
TOUCH THE PARKING LOT IN A
RETROFIT. RIGHT WHEN THEY'RE
GOING AND THEY'RE DOING
REDEVELOPMENT ANYWAYS THAT IS
TOUCHING THE PARKING LOT NOT
LIKE A BUILDING OVER HERE SO
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT- IS THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT'S COST
EFFECTIVE TRIGGER TO LINE
WITHOUT USING THE CAL GREENE
STANDARD. THE AMENDMENT- SORRY I
PROBABLY NEED TO PUT ON MY
READERS FOR THIS- SORRY. I HAVE
TO PUT ON MY READERS ONE TWO
THERE WE GO THE THIRD AMENDMENT-
IS- THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
SECTION WHICH ALIGNS WITH THOSE
IN THE CARAVAN STANDARDS- THE
FOURTH ONE IS. A DEFINITION
PROPOSING INDICES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WHICH
SPECIFIES THE TYPE OF STRUCTURES
H. C. D. AND E. S. A. ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. NUMBER FIVE IS-
AMEND THE BILL- SET FOR THE NEW
STANDARDS OF THE NEXT TRIENNIAL
COATED OPTION CYCLE RATHER THAN
NEXT INTERVENING COURT CYCLES
ABOUT THE TIMING SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THIS TIMING ISSUE OF
NEW STAND IT'S GOING TO AFFECT
PLUS A NEW BILL GOING TO THE
FACT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TIME
TO ALIGN IT- NUMBER SIX IS- AN
ADDITIONAL. RELEVANT CODE
SECTIONS TO PROVIDE BUILDING
STANDS REFLECT THE RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND PROPOSITION FOR
ADOPTION LANGUAGE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE REGULATORY PROCESS RIGHT
SO THAT WE ALIGN WITH YOUR
STANDARD OF HOW YOU DO THINGS IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE. THE
SEVENTH AMENDMENT. IS-
CONFORMING CHANGES TO MAKE THE
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT ADOPTION
LANGUAGE THROUGHOUT THE BILL.
THE EIGHTH AMENDMENT IS- THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE SECTION
TO ACQUIRE THE RELEVANT
PROPOSING ENERGY CONSIDER
STANDARDS FOR EASY CHARGING
STATIONS. IN EXISTING BUILDINGS
ONLY ONE SIGNIFICANCE
CONSTRUCTION RETROFITS REPAIR
ACTION IS TAKEN IF YOU LOOK THE
OPPOSITION LETTER THERE WAS A
CONCERN THAT AS SOON AS THIS
BILL WENT INTO EFFECT. IT WOULD
REQUIRE EVERY MULTI FAMILY UNIT
ACROSS THE STATE TO INSTALL IN
THE CHARGING WHICH IS NOT THE
INTENT THAT WAS NOT OUR
INTENTION SO WE TOOK THE BILL. I
AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY THAT. AND
THE LAST ONE IS TO CHANGE THE
CONTINUE UPDATING REQUIREMENT
ONLY TO BE IN EFFECT UNTIL
ADEQUATE CAR CHARGING CAPACITY
IS MET IN THE SHORT TERM. AND IN
THE LONG TERM. SO THOSE ARE THE
NINE MM IS THAT WE'VE TAKEN TO
CLARIFY. THE UP YOU KNOW WELL
WAS SOME OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
WERE JUST TAKEN TO MAKE THE BILL
BETTER. RIGHT AND EVER AGAIN
THANK THE STAFF FOR THE AND THE
AND THE CHAIR FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS. SO SOME OF THEM WERE TAKEN
TO MAKE THE BILL BETTER MORE
CONSISTENT BECAUSE I WROTE IT
MYSELF AND THAT'S WHAT YOU GET
WHEN YOU WRITE BILLS OR
SOMETHING AND A LAWYER- AND THEN
SOME OF THEM WERE TAKEN TO AND
FROM THEIR AGE. ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION ABOUT
WHAT WAS THE TRIGGER WHAT WOULD
TRIGGER THE REQUIREMENT FOR
EV'S- INSTALLATION. AND THOSE
AMENDMENTS STANDING YOU'RE ALSO
COMMITTING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS HUNDRED PERCENT. THIS A.
L. I THINK I IT WHEN I WHEN I
READ A BILL. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE OUTCOME. AND WHAT I SEE IS
WHAT WE'RE ON A TRACK FOR
CALIFORNIA. IS ASKING
DEVELOPERS- TO. PUT IN THE
PLUMBING AND NOT. THE CHARGER.
AND SO THAT THE PLUMBING IS
THERE IS THE COST AND THAT COST
IS GOING TO COME NO MATTER WHAT.
THE QUESTION IS DO WE MAKE IT
USEFUL FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AND THAT'S THE
OUTCOME AND I'M TRYING TO
ACHIEVE. AND SO I'M AGAIN WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION- AND TO MAKE THIS
THE BEST BILL THEY CAN BE. TO
ACHIEVE THAT OUTCOME. SERIAL
THANK- MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR I JUST WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL- APPLIED YOU I
THINK THE BROADER OBJECTIVE OF
THIS BILL IS ONE THAT I TOTALLY
SUPPORT AND I KNOW HOW-
COMMITTED YOU ARE TO YOU- OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I ALSO KNOW
YOU HAVE BEEN A CONCERN CAUCUS
RECORD ISSUES- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND SO I THINK THE BROADER
INTENTION OF THIS BILL- TO BRING
EVEY CHARGERS INTO MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING AND EACH OTHER SOME OF
THESE OTHER PLACES WHERE WE
WOULD PUT THEM IS A VERY LOT OF
ALL AND ONE THAT I SUPPORT I
GUESS WHAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH
AND UNITE HAD. UNFORTUNATE TO
BRIEF OF AN OPPORTUNITY TALK
ABOUT THIS IS- SOME OF THE
DETAILS AND I GUESS THE THINGS
I'M MOST WILL HAVE MOST OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT. IS HOW THIS IS
DONE. THE PROCESS TO WHICH THESE
THIS IS MANDATED AND THEN WHO
PAYS FOR IT AND SO THOSE ARE THE
TWO THINGS I WANTED TO CHAT WITH
YOU ABOUT- I'M LOOKING BACK AT
THAT ARE CALLING MR LEVINE'S
BILLS FROM- PRIOR SESSIONS. I
NOTICED THE DAY ARE WORKING
THROUGH THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION WHICH I THINK IS ONE
OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION AND SO. MY
UNDERSTANDING. HAVING GONE INTO
THIS ISSUE A LITTLE BIT IN YOU
KNOW PREVIOUS. PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS WITH OUR
PRIOR CHAIRS THAT- THERE WAS A
THERE WAS A STRONG PREFERENCE
FROM I THINK FROM OUR PRIOR
CHAIR TO WORK THROUGH THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
AND I SEE. YOU KNOW WE SEE THAT
HERE IN IN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO MESSAGE SO. MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS WHY NOT WORK. SORT OF
THROUGH THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION AND WHY DO THIS
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE SO ONE
OF THE THINGS I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT IS. WHEN THE REGULATIONS
WERE ADOPTED IN DECEMBER. THEY
DIDN'T DO A STANDARD FOR EASY
INSTALLED. AT AS POLICY MAKERS.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT CHARGER.
NO ONE AND WHO'S A RENTER AND AN
APARTMENT. IS GOING TO GET IN
THE V. I WANT TO GET A VVV AND
I'M ONE OF THE FEW RENTERS IN
THE ASSEMBLY. YOU KNOW WE- ARE
NOT GONNA SPEND A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO INSTALL. A PROPER
CHARGER WE USE A PLUG SO IT
TAKES EIGHTEEN HOURS. TO CHARGER
EVEY. RIGHT SO I LOOK AT THAT
AND LIKE I CAN DO THAT BECAUSE
OF A SINGLE FAMILY HOME WITH A
BRUSH. BUT IF YOU'RE AN
APARTMENT A YOU DON'T HAVE A WAY
TO CHARGE YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO
BUY EASY. AND SO WE WILL HAVE IT
AND THEY DIDN'T ADOPTED. SO I'M
HAPPY TO LOOK AT GOING THROUGH
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WE'VE TAKEN A MOMENT SET
TO MAKE IT BETTER WITH YOUR
PROCESS. BUT I'M OPEN I JUST
WANT TO GET TO THE PLACE AND
THAT HAVE THE EEVEE INSTALLED
THAT'S WHAT I WANT OKAY SORRY I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DO
YOU HAVE ANY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION DECLINED TO DO THAT.
I ASSUME IT WAS A PROCESS OF
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. AND BUT IT
DOES. THE REALITY IS HOW THEY
GOT TO THE PLACE WHERE EVEN
INSTALLED. MAYBE IT WAS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WELL THAT WASN'T
FUNDING SO WE HAVE THE FUNDING
BILL AS I MENTIONED BEFORE-
THAT'S ON THE OTHER SIDE. SO
THAT COULD CHANGE THE
CALCULATION. AND THE OTHER THING
THAT I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
ABOUT THE CALCULATION. IS EVEN
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WHICH I KNOW IS NOT A
FINAL BUDGET. THEY'RE PUTTING A
LOT OF MONEY FOR EV'S IN THERE.
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY THIS
YEAR I THINK A COMMITMENT. FROM
ALL SIDES TO ADDRESS. THE
FUNDING SIDE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S THE THING- AND- AND I
THINK THAT. WE AS POLICYMAKERS
NEED TO MAKE CLEAR. THIS IS WHAT
OUR OBJECTIVE IS. I AM HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU IN YOUR OFFICE. ON
ACHIEVING OUR MUTUALLY AGREED
UPON GOALS YEAH I GUESS IT WOULD
BE REALLY IMPORTANT HELPFUL FOR
ME TO UNDERSTAND WHY THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
DECLINED TO DO THAT AND I. AND I
SUSPECT THAT I KNOW THE REASON
WHY- AND THAT'S BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE IN THE ANALYSIS FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. HE TALKS
ABOUT BALANCING ARCHED CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE OBJECTIVES. WITH
OUR EFFORTS TO EXPAND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THAT GETS TO MY
SECOND CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL.
WHICH IS COST BECAUSE- THIS
ISN'T GONNA BE FREE RIGHT
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A FREE
LUNCH AND WHEN YOU PUT THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- SOMEBODY HAS
TO PAY FOR IT. AND WHAT I WORRY
ABOUT IS THAT. THE PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE GONNA PASS THOSE
COSTS ALONG TO THE RENTER'S
ALONG TO THE TENANTS. ALONG TO
WHOEVER THOSE FOLKS MAY BE. AND
IF THIS IF THIS ISN'T CRAFTED IN
THE RIGHT WAY. YOU COULD
LITERALLY END UP BECOMING A
REPRESS A REGRESSIVE TAX WE
COULD BE INCREASING RENTS. IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WOULD WE
COULD BE INCREASING RENTS IN- IN
IN MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS. IN A
WAY THAT I HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS AROUND THAT'S WHY I
THINK THAT THIS IS. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE STRUGGLE WITH IN
THIS COMMITTEE I SUPPORTED A LOT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL MANDATES. ON
OUR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE DRIVING
UP THE COST OF HOUSING IN THE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT WE
HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT THAT
THESE ARE POLICY TRADE OFFS AND
SO. WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS
THAT WE'RE JUMPING IN HERE- IT
KNOWING THAT. IN ADMINISTRATION
AND I THINK. AS YOU MENTIONED
THIS IS A RESTRICTION THAT IS
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO EXPANDING IF
YOU TRY. INTEREST DEEPLY COMMIT
HARD BY. GOALS THIS IS A
GOVERNOR THAT'S ACTUALLY TAKEN
STEPS THAT ARE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO TYPE. THEY WERE A
LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT DOING THIS
PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT HOW WHAT IMPACT
OUR HOUSING SUPPLY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
JUMP IN AND SO I'M- I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT ISSUE SO
TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY OF THIS BECOMING
A REGRESSIVE TAX. SO THIS IS NOT
A REGRESSIVE TAX MR GABRIEL. AND
I THINK FRAMING IT AS SUCH. YOU
COULD FRAME ANY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS THAT WE DO.
YOU CAN IN THE- FRAME. PUTTING
SOLAR ON ROOFS AS- A REGRESSIVE
TAX YOU COULD. FRAME ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO AS A
REGRESSIVE TAX I DON'T THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT. I THINK WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE TO WERE PUTTING
STORM WATER RETENTION BASINS
BASINS WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAN TO
PUT IN  FAST CHARGER. AND THIS
BILL IS ALLOWING. MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENT UNIT OWNERS. TO
PARTNER WITH ALL OF OUR EVEY
CHARGING COMPANIES. THEY DO NOT.
BEARING THE BURDEN OF IT. RIGHT
THAT WE PUT IN A LOT OF
SAFEGUARDS AROUND. MY OTHER BILL
THAT THE REVENUE TAX IS LOOKING
AT THE GRANT PROGRAM. BECAUSE
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND COSTS
THAT ARE GOING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THAT WILL TARGET
ESPECIALLY. THAT TAX INCENTIVE
RELIEF OR THE GRANT AND SENSE OF
RELIEF PROGRAM. AT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO THAT BILL TOGETHER
WITH THIS BILL AND THEIR THEIR
THEIR COMPANION BILLS WHAT
THEY'RE NOT. PHYSICALLY JOINED
UP IN LANGUAGE YET BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT HOW THE PROCESS WORKS
TO DO THAT IN THE SENATE. YOU
DON'T DO THAT IN THE ASSEMBLY.
BUT THEY ARE. WE WROTE THEM
TOGETHER WE'RE MOVING THEM
FORWARD TOGETHER. AND THAT
ADDRESSES YOUR ISSUE AROUND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT THOSE COSTS TO BE.
PASSED ON TO THE RENTERS WHICH
IS WHY THE- TAX INCENTIVE
PROGRAM OR THE TAX CREDIT.
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM. WILL BE
GOING SPECIFICALLY TALKING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. I APPRECIATE THAT
BUT TO ME THAT'S NOT. TO ME WHO
PAYS FOR IT IS NOT A MINOR
DETAIL. AND AGAIN YOU KNOW WHAT
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE SUPPORTING
THIS IS THERE SOME KIND OF AND I
KNOW THAT YOU WORKED ON A TAX
CREDIT IN THE COMMITTEE WASN'T
IN LOVE WITH THAT IDEA SO MAYBE
A GRANT PROGRAM. IF WE CAN
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND OR-
OTHER MAKE. FUNDING STILL. OF
THE THINGS WITH. WE CAN THAT WE
ARE PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
EASY CHARGING STATIONS BUT WE'RE
NOT PUTTING THE COST OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE ON SOME OF OUR
MOST RENT BURDENED FOLKS I MEAN
YOU WE ALL OF THE STUDIES WE'VE
SEEN ABOUT. HOW MUCH OF PEOPLE'S
INCOME RENT IS HEATING UP. LET'S
WORK WITH THAT LET'S LET'S
FIGURE OUT THE FUNDING MECHANISM
SO THAT WE'RE DRAWING FROM. A
BROADER GROUP OF FOLKS TO PAY
FOR IT. RATHER THAN HAVING THOSE
COSTS BE BORNE BY THE RENTERS
pTHAT IS WHERE INSTRUCTORS I
THINK YOU'VE HIT ON A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS NOTION IN
ECONOMICS THAT SUPPLY CREATES
ITS OWN DEMAND THAT YOU WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU START INSTALLING. EVEY
CHARGING STATIONS THAT WILL OPEN
UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS IN
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING TO BUY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES I THINK THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR CLIMATE
GOALS. BUT IF WE'RE ON ONE HAND.
YOU KNOW DOING A LITTLE
SOMETHING TO UP OUR CLIMATE
GOALS AND ON THE OTHER HAND.
MAKING AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
WORSE. NOT SURE THAT WE'VE MADE
THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE IN IN
IN THE WAY THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DO THAT AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'D
LIKE TO THINK ABOUT. HOW DO WE
FUND THIS IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
KNOW. THAT IT'S NOT IMPOSING.
ADDITIONAL COSTS ON OUR MOST
REDFORD FOLKS SO I THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I'M STRUGGLING WITH THIS
BILL TODAY- YOU HAVE ASKED ME
FOR A COURTESY VOTE I'M I'M- YOU
KNOW THINKING ABOUT DOING THAT
IF THERE'S A COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN A AND
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. BUT I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL IN
ITS CURRENT VERSION SO I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THAT COURTESY
VOTE TODAY BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
HARD YOU WORK AND YOU KNOW HOW
THOUGHTFUL YOU ARE. BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM
YOU. THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THESE ISSUES
THAT THERE'S- A FUNDING ISSUE.
RESERVE MY RIGHT ON THE FLOORTO
VOTE DIFFERENTLY OF COURSE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT MR GABER.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE IS
THAT ALL YOU NEED TO LOOK AT FOR
THE FUNDING MECHANISM AND ANY
FEEDBACK THAT YOU HAVE OR- MISS
QUIRK-SILVA THAT YOU HAVE.
AROUND THAT THAT'S WHERE THAT
ALL THAT SO THAT WAS ALL GOING
THERE. WE DECIDED VERY
STRATEGICALLY TO PUT. THAT THERE
AND THEN THIS IS THIS IS A
HOUSING AND THAT THAT WAS THE
EASY BILL RIGHT. WE TALKED ABOUT
DO WE DO IT ALL TOGETHER. IT
WOULD GET TROUBLE REFERRED. IT'S
SO EASY TO KILL SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. BUT WE'RE PUTTING IT
TOGETHER SO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. I'LL MAKE SURE MY FOR
EFFORT TO THAT YOURSELF CAN.
MAYBE GO HAVE A- TALK ABOUT. I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE COMMERCE. AND
I ALSO THINK THAT THAT THINKING
THROUGH. AND UNDERSTOOD. WHY THE
BUILDINGS. CAN LOOKED AT THIS
ISSUE. ARRIVED AT A DIFFERENT.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT US TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE OF THEIR
DETERMINATION WISE. WE FEEL
REALLY STRONGLY ABOUT CLIMATE
WE'RE GONNA PUT A TON OF MONEY
TV THIS YEAR BUT WERE WORRIED
ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPONENT. I WANT UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE THEN MAYBE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO CRAFT A BETTER BELL.
YOU CAN REMOVE ALL OF THIS
OPPOSITION AND WE CAN DO
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL FEEL
GOOD ABOUT. I ALWAYS WANT TO
BETTER BILL MR GABRIEL. THANK
YOU. SORRY MIT CONCERNS ARE
SIMILAR- THAT'S WHY I ALWAYS
LIKE HIM TO GO FIRST. A VERY
ELOQUENT AND- STADIUMS. HOWEVER
I HAVE JUST A LITTLE BIT OF A-
DIFFERENT SPIN ON THIS. FOR ME
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS.
ADVANCING IN MARKET BEFORE IT'S
OF IT IF. IT'S READY- THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE. ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOMES AND- AFFORDABLE APARTMENT.
THEY THEY CAN'T EVEN DREAM OF
OWNING. AN EEVEE. AND YET WHAT
THIS IS DOING IS
ADVANCINGJUSTICE THAT'S GOING TO
BE IMMEDIATELY PASSED ALONG TO
THEM SPECIFICALLY. AS IT. IS A
COST SHARING FOR IS IT IT'S A
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY APARTMENT
BUILDING. ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE
GONNA BE SHARING IN THE COSTS.
OF EVEY THAT ONLY MAYBE TEN
PEOPLE ARE USING. AND THIS IS
THE CONCEPT OF HAVING THEM BUILD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE UP TO THE
BUILDING IS SOMEWHAT LIKE FILES
WAS WAY BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND.
WHEN I THINK HUNTINGTON BEACH IS
THE FIRST CITY. THAT HAD FILES
PUT IN. THEY PUT IT IN UP TO THE
SERVICE. THE UP TO THE STREET.
UP TO THE THIS WHAT THE SERVICE
ADDRESS. BUT IT WAS UP TO THE
CUSTOMER TO DO THE REST OF IT.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT EVENT.
WILL HAPPEN IS. MARKET WILL
FORCE. OF THE- PEOPLE WHO OWN.
THE BUILDINGS TO SAY HEY YOU
KNOW WHAT. OF PARTICULAR PEOPLE
ARE STARTING DECLINE TO RENT OR
PAY THE RENTS WE ARE ARE
CHARGING BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
VIS AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY V.
PLACE FOR THEM AND THAT'S THE
POINT AT WHICH THEY START ADDING
THOSE ON AND THEY CAN THEY CAN
ADD THOSE ON AND BE PART OF THE
RANT- BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
WILL BE RIGHT WE KEEP IMPACTING
THE VERY THING THAT WE'RE TRYING INCREASING THE
COSTS FOR THE FOR THE VIVID UP
POINT BUILDING OF SOMETHING THAT
MAKES THE OF RENTS AND THE COST
OF HOMES UNAFFORDABLE- IF I'M
NOT GOING TO OWN AN EEVEE UNTIL
I ABSENT TELL MY- CAR DIES.
WHICH IS GOING TO HAPPEN- ARE
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT TO
PAY FOR HER T. V. STATION IT'S
SITTING IN MY GARAGE AND HANG IN
THERE FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS AND USED- AND I THINK IT'S
BETTER TO LET THE MARKET.
ADVANCED HIS GOALS. IN WILL OF
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW A LOT OF CAN'T
EVEN AFFORD AN EEVEE AND THEY
WON'T FOR A LONG TIME AND- SO
UNTIL THAT MARKET COMES INTO
PLAY I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
IMPACTING THE LOW THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PART OF THIS FAR MORE
CHEN WERE MAKING A DENT IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PART OF IT SO
THAT'S WHERE I WENT ON AND IF I
CAN RESPOND TO THAT SO WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS THE MARKET IS
BUILDING EV'S. RAN UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS AND UPPER CLASS
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY CITY WHEN I
KNEW ABOUT DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR
AUTOMATICALLY INSTALLING ATVS
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE NOT DOING
THAT THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT ANTI
ONE INVESTOR THEY'RE NOT DOING
THAT OF SOME PARTS OF OCEANSIDE
AND THAT'S NOT DOING THAT.
BECAUSE THE- BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A TO DO IT AND THERE'S NO
AND TO DO AND SO IF WE WAIT FOR
THE MARKET TO DO AT TO DECIDE
WHEN LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO EV'S WE ARE
EXACERBATING EXISTING INEQUITIES
AND STATE AND I THINK I KNOW AND
WE MADE THIS DISAGREE ON THIS- I
THINK THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT SO MUCH ON THIS BILL
IS BECAUSE- IT AND IT'S NOT LIKE
OVERNIGHT SOMEBODY HAS TO BUILD
US RIGHT WE WENT NEXT AND- THE
NEXT CYCLE SO NOT INTERVIEW.
CYCLEWITH THE NAY THING MONTHS
WE TOOK I'M- PLEASE BECAUSE IT
WILL BE AS YOU TO I MEAN IF YOU
LOOK AT MOST MORE MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENTS THEY DON'T PICK UP
THE PARKING LOT VERY OFTEN IT'S
NOT LIKE THEY DID HAVE A PARKING
LOT USUALLY MOST MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPERS WILL AVOID ANYTHING
THAT TRIGGERS THE STORM WATER
RETENTION BASIN REQUIREMENTS THE
PARKING LOTS AND SO THEY WILL
AVOID DEVELOPING BEYOND THAT
UNLESS THERE IS A MARKET
INCENTIVE TO DO SO THE MORE THEY
WANT TO DO THIS UNLESS THERE WAS
A MORE SENSITIVE SO IT TRIGGER
FOR THIS IT MEANT TO BE GRADUAL
SO THAT WE- GET TO THE PLACE.
THAT BY TWO WE DO HAVE AN
EXPANSIVE NETWORK AND WE'RE
BEING INCLUSIVE OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IT AND RENTERS I
THINK THIS IS MORE ABOUT RENTERS
AND LOW INCOME THE MORE OF THE
MIDDLE- AND FROM SOUTH WITH I
APPRECIATE YOUR POSITION AND
MAYBE HOW A DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT
THAT ACTUAL YOU CAN ANSWER ONE
OF THE ISSUES IS THAT HIGHER AND
MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY AFFORD EV'S AND THAT'S
WHY IT HAPPENED AND BUILT THEIR
WHEREAS THE OTHER. COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE AS MANY
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD THEY'RE NOT
DOING THAT THEY'RE AND THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD
IT I MEAN I CAN NO MORE EASY
CHARGERS AND HIGHER INCOME AND
THEY'RE PUTTING THEM IN PUBLIC
SPACES TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE FEW THAT THERE ARE BUT AS
THEIR BECOME MORE MORE I SAID IN
AN APARTMENT COMPLEX THAT'S
BEING BUILT IF THAT'S ONE OF THE
DETERMINING FACTORS WHETHER
YOU'RE GOING RUN WHEN I. THE
MORE AS WHAT WE BETTER START
PUTTING IN A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THAT'LL ACCOMMODATE THOSE PEOPLE
NOT NOT ONE FOR EVERY UNIT I'M
NOT ASKING FOR WHEN I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT I KNOW I'M JUST
SAYING THAT IT'S EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU FOR IS ON
THE WAY I APPRECIATE IT WORK
WITH YOU WE ARE AND WE'RE GOING
TO GET TO A PLACE OF AGREEMENT
RIGHT THANK. YOU NEITHER. ANY
OTHER FROM THE DYESS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECT FOR ASK
FOR NIGHT OUT AND I WILL CAN
WORKING ON THE BTS AND- CAN
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
ANYBODY HERE WHOSE INTEREST IN
THIS I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT IT
OBVIOUSLY I WOULD WELCOME YOUR
FEEDBACK AND INPUT THANK YOU AND
THE CLASS FOR LIFE. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND WE DO
OKAY SEVERAL- MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN EDUCATION WICKS I WICKS
I SAY I DON'T KNOW THEY ARE NO
CARILLO. I GABRIEL GABRIEL I.
KALRA KILEY QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I WARD. WARD I THINK
YOU AND THAT BILL IS OUT AND
LET'S TAKE ROLE ON- THE BILLS
THAT WE- I HEARD EARLIER WHEN WE
WERE IN. BEFORE WE HAD QUORUM I
BELIEVE IT'S A- STARTING WITH MR
BERMAN RIGHT. YEAH INTO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND I KNOW WE
DON'T SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND FOR MR BERMAN'S BILL MISS
CARILLO TIME. AB TWENTY SIXTY
THREE OKAY SECOND. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THIS IS FOR A BILL AB
TWO ZERO SIX THREE- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN LOCAL GOVERNMENT WEEKS
FIVE WEEKS THEY SAY ARE TOO HIGH
SEE R. NIGHT CORREO. I GABRIELLE. ABSOLUTELY. IT'S MISS BERMAN
AB. TWENTY THREE. TWO ZERO SIX
THREE THAT'S TIED NUMBER. FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL I. KALRA
KILEY QUIRK-SILVA KIRKSEY I WORK
FOR TI. IF THAT BILLS OUT. AND
WE ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWO
TWO SEVEN ASSEMBLY REYES WE NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND FOR THAT
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE. MOTION BY
MISS QUIRK-SILVA A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. THE MOTION FOR
THIS BILL IS DUE PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WICKS I'M WEEKS I SEYARTO THEY
ARE THE NO CARILLO. GLORIA I
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I KALRA. KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA OKAY VI<c.cyan> WARD WAR</c>
DIE. AT THE END OF BILLS OUT THE
CONSENT- A OF THE CONSENT
COUNTER. MOTION BY MISTER-
QUIRK-SILVA BY MISS WARD- MOSHE
TO PASS THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN.
WICKS WEEKS SAY C. R. CARILLO
ARE YOU ARE YOU GABRIELLE. EVERY
CABRIOLET YES THIS ITEM CORRECT
ARCHIVE AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL. KILEY QUIRK-SILVA KIRK'S VICE
WARD OR DIE THAT IS OUT GRAY
OKAY GOING BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
ANYTHING MR LEE OR AFP AND- A
BEACH. FIFTY THANK YOU MATT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS VERY- INTO.
IT'S A REAL AND- TODAY AND PER
MY L. ACTIVE WHICH IS A UP TO AB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR EARLIER IN THE
YEAR WHERE PRE VERSIONS OF BILL
PASSED OUT OF THIS AND ON THE S.
FOR JANUARY. THE BILL SEEKS TO
PER SPEC FICTION BY REQUIRE FIVE
YEARS A PROP OWNERS BEFORE THE
ALSO CAN BE IN THE IN GETTING
FIVE YEARS FROM THE TIME THAT
AND BY WHETHER BE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH THOUSAND FOR. THE L.
SECTOR ORIGINALLY TO ALLOW MOM
AND POP LANDLORDS LEAVE THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS WITH
DOUBTS ON THE PROPERTY I
RECRUITING A FIVE YEAR HOLDING
PERIOD. BEFORE DIAZ THAT CAN BE
INVOKED. ARBIL CONTINUES RESPECT
LONG TERM LANDLORDS WHO HAVE
BEEN IN THE BUSINESS FOR DECADES
IN THIS VERSION OF THE BILL WE
HAVE PUT FORWARD AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFIED AT THIS BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO MOM AND POP LANDLORDS
WHO MAY MANAGE THEIR PROPERTY
WITH AN LLC OR TRUST. THE
EXEMPTION APPLIES IF THE OWNER
IS THE NATURAL PERSON THE OWNERS
LLC MADE ENTIRELY OF NATURAL
PERSONS THE OWNER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY OWNS NO MORE THAN
FOUR RESIDENTIAL UNITS IN THE
AGGRGATE INCLUDING OR EXCLUDING
THEIR PERSONAL PLACE OF
RESIDENCE AND THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS O PREVENT THE ABUSE OF
PROPERTY SPECULATORS FROM MOVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS FOR
PROFIT. IF AB TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW LATER THIS YEAR
ANYONE WHO HAS OWNED A PROPERTY
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND PRIOR
CAN STILL USE THE ELLIS ACT EXIT
THE RENTAL BUSINESS TOO OFTEN
MANY TENANTS IN THE RENT
STABILIZED UNITS LIVE IN
CONSTANT FEAR THAT THEY'RE
BUILDING WILL BE SOLD TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER. CAN BE SUBJECT
TO AN EVICTION SHOW AFTER
PASSING THIS BILL UP CRUCIAL
STABILISING EFFECT WHEN RENTERS
WILL NOT HAVE TO WORRY THAT A
NEW OWNER IS GOING TO EVICT THEM
WITHIN MONTHS OF CLOSING ESCROW.
SINCE 200-012-7000 SIX HUNDRED
TEN UNITS IN LOS ANGELES ALONE
HAVE BEEN TAKEN OFF THE RENTAL
MARKET USING THE RENTS USING THE
ALSO ACT DISPLACING OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. CONTINUED ABUSE
OF ELSE ACT DOES NOT PRODUCE
HOUSING IT PRODUCES DISPLACEMENT
AND WORSENS OUR HOUSING CRISIS
BY LOVING REAL ESTATE
SPECULATORS A PROFIT MOTIVE TO
REMOVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. THERE ARE I'M PRESIDENT
HOUSING CRISIS WE MUST IN.
DEFENSIVE MEASURE AGAINST PLACE
AND HOMELESSNESS. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TO IS A- RAIL. MORE
OF ACTIONS AND MORE PEOPLE
LOSING THE ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS. AND INCLUDES AMENDMENTS
FROM CONCERNS I'VE HEARD FROM
OTHER MEMBERS THROUGH THE
PROCESS. SHORTLY AFTER I VOTE
AND TODAY AND JOIN IN PERSON BY
BRIAN AUGUSTA FROM THE C. R. L.
A. FOUNDATIONS. GOOD MORNING
TERM MEMBERS TRYING TO GUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION-
ZERILLI FOUNDATION AND OUR
COLLEAGUES WESTERN CENTER. AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
INTERNALLY CONSISTENT WITH THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE ELLIS ACT
RIGHT TELL US. THE PROPONENTS OF
THE ELLIS ACT. CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE MANY YEARS AGO AND
SAID. LOCAL REGULATIONS AND THE
NATIONAL CASE PREVENT US FROM
GOING OUT OF THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS AND
WANT TO EXIT. THE BUSINESS
EFFECT- INTO THE BUILDING AND
CHANGE ITS USE. ABNETT WHAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT THAT THAT IS STILL THERE
RIGHT. AND THOSE PROPERTY
OWNERS. CAN STILL DO THAT AND IN
FACT- THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN
THIS VERSION OF THE BILL. FOCUS
ON ONE OF THE- CRITICS THAT WE
HEARD IN THE LAST ROUND WHICH
WAS THAT. SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
MOM AND POP. A FAMILIES WHO WANT
TO BUY RENTAL PROPERTY AND MOVE
MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
WOULD BE PRECLUDED FROM DOING SO
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT BY
CREATING THAT EXEMPTION. SO WHAT
THIS BILL IS REALLY TARGETING
IS- SPECULATORS. WHO HAD NO
INTENTION OF EVER BEING IN THE
REAL HOUSING BUSINESS THEY
PURCHASED AN ONGOING RENTAL
HOUSING- PROPERTY AND
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS THE ELLIS ACT
TO. PREEMPT LOCAL EVICTION
PROTECTIONS EFFECT ALL OF THE
TENANTS. AND CHANGE THE USE OF
THE BUILDING AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS BILL TO
PUT AN END TO THE SPECULATORS
THE SERIAL VICTORS. WHO WHO ARE
ABUSING THE ELLIS ACT AND
CAUSING. ENORMOUS HARM IN OUR
CITIES AMONG. THE MOST
VULNERABLE RIGHT. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS AND ALL THE RE THAT THE
AUTHORS TO WE WOULD AND I. ON ON
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. PRIMARY WHAT IS IN
SUPPORT. I'M NOT AND NOT PRIME
NOT PRIMARY OKAY- LET'S GO TO A
PRIMARY WITNESSES WERE NOT AT ME
TO SEE THAT WOULD HAVE- RIGHT.
YEAH NO SORRY ALL GOING TO USE
NAME ORGANISER. AND THEN SOME
EXERCISE YEAH. I'M SURE MEMBERS
RANDOM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE. AND IT'S A
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
DIVISION IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
HI GUYS DIVINING HERE WITH EASE
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL HE TENANTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING TO
SUPPORT STATEWIDE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NAME ORGANIZATION AND
THE POSITION. YES MY NAME IS
SHARON BLACK AND GUESTS FOR A.
TWENTY FIFTY. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOING CAMP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI
I'M KRISTIN STAMBERG A WITH THE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT I'M HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIFTY ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
RENTERS AND EVERYBODY IN DANGER
OF BECOMING HOMELESS THANK YOU-
MARC STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA DAY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. DAVID CANTON ON
BEHALF OF BUILD AFFORDABLE
FASTER CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING JORDAN
PLAN A CAR BOMB TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ANYONE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
LET'S GO TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING AND THE
MEDICINE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WHEN I
THINK THE COMMITTEE PROVIDE
WOULD SPEAK THIS MORNING. SORRY
THE BETTER THANK YOU CAA'S HERE
OPPOSING AB TWENTY FIFTY AS IT
IS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO AB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR WHICH WAS
UNSUCCESSFUL JUST EARLIER THIS
YEAR. WHAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHORS EFFORT TO LIMIT THE
APPLICATION OF AB TWENTY FIFTY
VERSUS THE PRIOR VERSION OF THE
BILL THE REVISIONS TO THE
DEFINITION OF A PROPERTY OWNER
STILL WOULD FOR SMALL RENTAL
OWNERS TO STAY IN BUSINESS WHEN
THEY CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO DO
SO. THIS BILL IS NOT THE
SOLUTION OUR STATE NEEDS OR ITS
HOUSING CRISIS INSTEAD OF
UNNECESSARILY PLACING LIMITS ON
EXISTING RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
LEGISLATION THAT INCREASES
CALIFORNIA SUPPLY RENTAL
HOUSING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU AND ANY
OTHER- FOLKS IN THE ROOM WHEN I
REGISTER OPPOSITION PLEASE NAME
AN ORGANIZATION A POSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PAT MORAN
WITHIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION OPPOSED
TO THE BILL FOR THE SAME REASON
TO CA THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. NO
OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK HERE TO
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER WARD BURNING QUESTION
HERE. SO YOUR OWN APARTMENT FOR
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS AND YOU
DECIDE YOU YOU'RE DONE WITH A
AND YOU HAVE A FEW OF THEM- SAY
TEN UNIT APARTMENT BUILDING. AND
DAY SO YOU DECIDE THAT YOU NO
LONGER WANT TO BE IN THE
BUSINESS SO YOU'RE GOING TO SELL
THAT APARTMENT BUILDING AND
YOU'RE SAYING THAT PERSON THAT
BUYS IT CAN'T. IS LIMITED ON
WHAT THEY CAN DO AS FAR AS
RANCID SECTOR CONCERNED
RENOVATING THE BUILDING. CORRECT
FOR FIVE YEARS. SO WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IF I WERE A
PROPERTY OWNER WHO ATTEND UNITS
AND THEN I SOLD IT TO SOMEONE
ELSE THAT NEW PERSON COULD NOT
USE THE L. SACK TO MASSIVE ECHT
EVERYONE WITHIN THE FIVE YEARS
OF LYING THAT. HE CAN STILL
RENOVATED THEY CAN STILL DO ON A
MOVE INS WHICH IS UNDER FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WITH THE PREVIOUS. A
BIG LEGISLATION BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM IS WHEN THAT OWNERSHIP
CHANGES HANDS ESPECIALLY FOR A
LONG TIME OWNER OF A TEN YEAR
APARTMENT- THAT TEN UNIT
APARTMENT IS GOING TO COST A
WHOLE. MORE IN THERE FOR THE
MONEY THAT- A IT TAKES TO
MAINTAIN THAT. IS GOING TO
CHANGE- YOU KNOW THE IN OTHER
WORDS. YOU'RE GONNA DRIVE THE
MARKET UP FOR. PEOPLE BUYING
APARTMENT BUILDINGS. AND DAD AND
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
INTERFERING IN THE MARKET LIKE
THAT- I THINK- MAY. DAY I THINK
IS GOING DOWN A ROAD. THAT IS.
BEING WAY TOO RESTRICTIVE ON
PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST TRY THEY'RE
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING TILL.
AND ANDERSTON- THE RENT CONTROL
BUT YOU KNOW. PEOPLE THAT ARE
RENTING HAVE LEASES- THAT ARE
USUALLY ONE YEAR. OR ONTH TO
MONTH. AND IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE IN THAT SITUATION THEN WE
NEED TO THAT EITHER THEY CAN
GIVE ENTERED LONGER LEASES. OR
OR THE YOU KNOW THE- STATE THEY
LIVE IN RENT CONTROL AREAS THAT
ARE ALREADY BEING IMPOSED ON ON.
THE RENTER ITSELF. YEAH I HAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT WHERE THIS
BILL IS HEADED OUR WAY THIS ACT
WITH THIS APPROACH IS HEADED IN
TERMS OF PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHTS- AND- THE MARKET. ITSELF
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THAT MARKET IS
WHAT TAKES A RUN DOWN APARTMENT
BUILDING. AND RENOVATED AND
TURNED IT INTO A- MUCH BETTER-
LIVIA LIVABLE UNITS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT- I MEMBER ONE
COMMITTEE MEETING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- THE NEED FOR EVERY UNIT
TO HAVE AIR CONDITIONING. WELL A
LOT OF THE OLD ONES DON'T
ESPECIALLY THE ONES DOWN IN THE
SOUTH BAY AREA THAT HAVE THE-
DID FAVORABLE CLIMATE. IN ORDER
TO DO THAT YOU'D HAVE TO HAVE A
AID OVERTURNED DO THEY HAVE TO
OVERTURN THE PROPERTY OR TURN
THE PROPERTY OVER. AND IN WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS ESSENTIALLY
THAT PERSON WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
DO ANY OF THOSE THINGS- BECAUSE
IT AND THE PEOPLE HAVE TO MOVE
OUT. AND OVER THERE AND THEY CAN
RATE YOU KNOW THEY CAN READ JUST
AS JUST AS THE RENT TO GO TO
MORE OF A MARKET RATE THAT WILL.
WILL HELP OFFSET THE COSTS OF
ACQUISITION FOR THAT BUILDING.
AND END WITHOUT OF A CLEAR- IDEA
OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE MARKET
IN THAT SPACE IT'S KIND OF HARD
TO COME UP STILL HARD FOR ME TO-
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
MR WARD. THANK YOU CHAIR- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL BACK
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE WORKING
REALLY HARD ON A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIES TO. AVOID
DISPLACEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS- I
THINK WELL I APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
SOME PERSPECTIVE IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS LET'S REMEMBER THAT
THERE ARE FEWER AND FEWER
CHOICES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
ACTUALLY GO TO. IF THEY CHOOSE
TO AND THAT ONE YEAR LEASE OR
THE OR THEY ARE ARE ARE ARE.
COMPELLED TO BE AFFECTED- AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO GRAPPLE WITH AS WELL AND SO.
THIS IS A BILL THAT IS REALLY
SENDING THOSE JUST BOUNDARIES
GOING FORWARD. AND THEY'RE
ALREADY RENT CONTROLLED
APARTMENTS RIGHT THAT FACT ISN'T
CHANGING- YOU ARE IF THIS WERE
TO BECOME LAW BASICALLY
CLARIFYING WHAT YOU CAN AND
CAN'T DO FOR THAT GOING FORWARD
FOR A PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS SO.
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A CHOICE AS
THE PURCHASER- WHETHER OR NOT-
UNDER THOSE TERMS THAT IS
SATISFACTORY TO YOU THAT THE
CHOICE IS STILL THERE- BUT THE
IMPORTANT THING TO MAKE SURE
THAT UNDER VERY. VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE HAVE TODAY
IS THAT WE'RE PROTECTING PEOPLE
FROM. THAT KIND OF DISPLACEMENT
RIGHT NOW AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK WITH MEMBERS- AND WITH
OPPOSITION AS WELL TO TRY TO
FIND TO THIS BILL AS YOU BROUGHT
IT BACK FOR- TO WORK ON NOT.
LIMITING IT TO THE EXEMPTIONS
FOR CERTAIN SMALL- SMALL.
MONOPOD OWNERS- DEFINING WHAT AN
ACTUAL PERSON IS THAT'S ALWAYS A
TRICKY LEGAL- ISSUE- BUT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE TELLING THIS
IN A WAY THAT I THINK IS VERY
HELPFUL TO SET THOSE BOUNDARIES-
SO THAT THE ULTIMATE OUTCOME
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE-
IS REALIZE FOR INDIVIDUALS. THAT
NEED. THANK YOU FOR THAT MANAGED
TO BE. THE MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU TO HAVE A SECOND ON THAT
MOST. BY MISTER. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. OKAY WELL- THANKS FOR BRING
THE BILL BACK AGAIN I KNOW
YOU'VE- A LOT OF WORK INTO IT
YOU'VE NARROWED IT- HOPEFULLY
GET SOME MORE VOTES WHEN WE
REACH THE FLOOR- BUT I'M
OPPOSITION I RECOMMENDATION
SAYING PRECIADO WORK. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
JUDICIARY WICKS I WEEKS I'D SAY
ARE TOO LOW C. R. TO KNOW.
CARILLO CARRILLO GABRIEL GABRIEL
I KALRA KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA WORK FOR TI. YEAH
THE BILLS OUT OKAY- WHY DON'T WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE WAITING RIGHT
NOW LET'S GO TO- JUDY WARD. YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO MISTER WARD.
MISTER GRAYSON WAS YOUR BODY
LOSES A SPOT MR WARD'S GONNA
JUMP IN.
AND EACH TIME I GO AHEAD AND BE
PRESENTING AND HOPEFULLY MY
SUPPORTER WILL ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT WE ARE PRESENTING A AB.
GOOD MORNING HI THERE ARE
VISITING AB SEVENTEEN NINETEEN-
UNDER FEDERAL LAW IF RESIDENTIAL
UNIT IS PROVIDED BY AN EMPLOYER
FOR ITS EMPLOYEES THE UNIT IS
NOT FOR USE BY THE PUBLIC AND IS
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
AFFORDABLE TAX CREDITS. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT
WHICH CLARIFIED THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT COULD LIMIT THE HOUSING
TO EMPLOYEES OF THE DISTRICT IN
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TAX CREDIT HOWEVER AB
THIRTY THREE WE DID NOT INCLUDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS SO.
THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN NINETEEN
ALLOWS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THE ABILITY TO MANAGE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY FOR
NECESSARY TAX CREDITS THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS WITH THE APPROPRIATE
EXISTING LAND AND RESOURCES TO
BE ACTIVE MEMBERS IN ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S EXASPERATED HOUSING
CRISIS. I WENT AND OF THE BILL
MARK MCDONALD REPRESENTING THE
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS- MARK MCDONALD MGI
ADVOCACY. WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
ALSO WITH THE PERALTA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN OAKLAND- AND
SUPPORT AND I THINK THE MEMBER
OF THE ANALYSIS DOES A GREAT JOB
LAYING OUT. THE PURPOSE OF THE
pWITH THE LARGE NUMBER OF PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS. THAT WE
HAVE A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF ON THIS CAN
BECOME- SOMETHING THAT WOULD-
INCENTIVIZE PART TIME FACULTY
AND CLASSIFIED STAFF. TO COME TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I WILL GO TO THE ROOM-
ANY FOLKS- IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN NINETEEN SAID MEMBER
WARDS BILL. NOT GONNA GRIFFIN ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEE COST
LIKE OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
. OKAY WILL NOW GO TO A PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TRIBUNE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE LIKE TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION. A MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED WE SHARE THE MEMBERS
WITH MISTER WARD STAFF AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THANK YOU. I WILL GO TO
COMMITTEE. I WILL SAY IS THE
AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT I OBVIOUSLY THINK THIS IS
A GREAT BELL I'M NOT SURPRISED
TO SEE THAT YOU AND I ARE LINED
HERE ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
YOU'VE BEEN SUCH A- SUCH A
LEADER ON HOUSING ISSUES. I'M
AND I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW
WHEN WE WERE WORKING ON THIRTY
THREE OH EIGHT WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT TEACHERS MANY TEACHERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY. WE'RE DRIVING TO
TWO HOURS OR MORE RIGHT BECAUSE
THEY'RE COMMITTEES OR THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LAUGH- AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO AFFORD
TO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY WORK- AND SO I'M VERY
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I REALLY APPLAUD YOU
FOR BEING A FORWARD. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. DO WE
HAVE. A MOTION. WE DIDN'T IN A
SECOND OKAY THE- IT'S TO PASS TO
A- ASSEMBLY CAN EDUCATION I'M
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTING THE BILL.
HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION. AS I ALWAYS
RECOMMEND. AND- PUBLIC THE BILL
GETS OUT TO KEEP DOING THAT.
WEARING CLOTHES OH SORRY YES YOU
CAN SLIDE ABSOLUTELY A PUT ON
THE RECORD AS WELL I APPRECIATE
ON THE OPPOSITION'S ARE
INTERESTED WELL WE ARE WORKING
ON- TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- THE THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
WORKERS. RELATED ISSUES- FOR
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS AND SO
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE WORKING
WITH THEM ON THIS- AND YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD. FOR THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- STUDENTS WHO
ARE INCREASINGLY FACING OR
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- THIS
IS A BILL IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THOSE PROPERTIES DO MORE
WITH THEIR PROPERTY- TO BE ABLE
TO HELP THE POPULATIONS OF
THESE- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU. WICKS
FIVE WEEKS I. DON'T KNOW. THEY
ARE NO. CARILLO KOREA. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I ECHO KILEY QUIRK-SILVA
QUIRK-SILVA WARD HI WHAT I THANK
YOU MR WARDEN THE BILL'S OUT- WE
WILL GO ANATOMISTS QUIRK-SILVA.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE FIVE.
THE LONG LONG. OKAY GO FOR IT.
YOU CAN GO YEAH WELL IT'S WE'VE
GOT FIVE BILLS LEFT SO. YEAH
MISS QUIRK-SILVA GONNA TALK FOR
A LONG TIME SO ENOUGH. MS
QUIRK-SILVA YOU MAY BEGIN GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE MY ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNIT BILL EIGHTY USE AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SORRY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY ONE WILL CLARIFY
EXISTING LAW TO HELP EXPEDITE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A D. USE.
I'LL JUST CHIME IN HERE THAT
WITH ALL OF OUR DISCUSSIONS FOR
MANY OF US OUR OUR AFTER OUR
POWER WE GOING TO GET HOUSING TO
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAS THIS HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE BRIGHT SPOTS AS
WE SEE MORE PERMITS BEING PULLED
AND MORE ES DE USE BEING BUILT.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA BROKE THE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
MEDIAN HOME PRICE. MARK FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY IF WE WANT
TO SUPPORT WORKING CALIFORNIANS
AND THERE'S PURSUIT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM OF OWNERSHIP
THAT WE MUST MAKE HOMES MORE
AFFORDABLE. AS WE KNOW ALL TOO
WELL BEFORE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OUR STATE WAS FACING
THE NATION'S WORST HOUSING
CRISIS THIS CRISIS HAS BEEN
EXASPERATED BY THE PANDEMIC
PARTICULARLY FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. A. D. USE ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS IN THIS MEASURE WILL HELP
HOMEOWNERS GET ACCESS TO EIGHTY
USE AND SPEED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WITH
ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WITH THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE IS. LOUISE LOUISE- LOUIS
LOUIS LOUIS SORRY LEWIS MERON
TAY WITH CALIFORNIA DMV AND ANTI
FRAME ME FRYMAN. THANK YOU MAY
BEGIN GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
FIRST APOLOGIES ANNIE IS UNABLE
TO MAKE IT.
I CALIFORNIA'S ORGANIZATION AND
WORKS AND CALIFORNIA'S THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOME SHORTAGE
AS YOU'D KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE
COST OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA IS
SOARING CONTINUES TO SOAR IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER BILLS HOUSING.
BY ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS PER YEAR. SINCE ITS
PASSAGE AT LAW HAS SPURRED THE
CREATION OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
NEW HOMES THAT ARE- IT
TRADITIONALLY ACCORDING TO THE
TURNER CENTER. NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE HOMES TO
PEOPLE WHO MAKE LOW INCOMES AND
THAT METRO AREA. THESE HOMES
HELP STABILIZE HOMEOWNERSHIP
GREAT HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. AND LIKE I SAID
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE RENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO THOSE WHO GET
THEM. THIS BILL MAKES SEVERAL
TECHNICAL CHANGES FOR EXAMPLE
THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTS MUST
RETURN A COMPLETE SET OF
COMMENTS. I TO AN EIGHTY
PROPONENT WITHIN THE TIMELINE OF
EXISTING LAW. CLARIFIES THAT ALL
RELEVANT PERMITTING AGENCIES
MUST RETURN THESE COMMENTS AND
MORE CLEARLY ENUMERATE THE ITEMS
TO LOCAL AGENCIES CANNOT CANNOT
REQUIRE OF A PROJECT APPROVED
UNDER SUBDIVISION E. OF EIGHTY
LAKH WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
RIGHT. OF ANY HOMEOWNER TO BUILD
EIGHT AN EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT ATO NOTWITHSTANDING A LOCAL
ORDINANCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE- AND- I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT WAY
OF ACCELERATING THE SUCCESS OF
EIGHTY LAKH CURRENTLY. THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE. AT
THE THAT WOULD ASSIST. GONNA IT
IS THAT RIGHT. YEAH AND I GOT
STUCK ON OKAY SORRY NO WAY- ANY
OTHER WITNESSES SOMEONE OUT ON
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WELL WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. THE BILL. MOVE
WITH THE MOTION IS THAT THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- JUST I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY. LIKE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK-SILVA I APPRECIATE YOUR
HARD WORK AS ALWAYS AND
PRESENTING A NICE BILL WITH THE
ROPE RIBBON ON IT- PLEASE TAKE
ROLE. WICKS I THINK I SEYARTO. I
CARILLO. CARILLO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL ID KALRA KILEY COOK. ICE. WARD WORD HI. YOUR BILL IS AND
I'M TAKE HOT SEAT.
WE'RE GOING NEXT BILL IS AB TWO
TWO FOR FOUR VICE MEMBER WICKS
MANAGER YOU HAVE THE FLOOR THANK
YOU MISTER ICE. TWO YEARS AGO
THE LATEST PASSED. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE TO REDUCE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THEIR
PROPERTY. THAT IS HELP
FACILITATE NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS FROM THE
BAY AREA SAN DIEGO HOWEVER AND
THIS WAS MY BILL WE NOTICED ONE
FLAW. IT'S NOT APPLIED TO NEW
PLACES OF WORSHIP SO ESSENTIALLY
ONE EXTEND THE SAME PROVISIONS
FOR NEW PLACES OF WORSHIP SO
THAT OUR CHURCHES CAN BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION WITH REGARD TO A
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND THEY
ARE- AND ALLOWED TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSES ON THE
PROPERTY AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND VOTE.
ALL RIGHT LOOKS LIKE WE NOT
HAVE. THE PRIMARY WHAT TELL US
EVERY. IS TO BE HERE. WHERE IS
ABRAM. MISTER DE IS GOING MAKE A
- CLEAN THE WHOLE. MISTER DE IS
WELCOME YOUR THE PRIMARY WITNESS
. WHEN YOU'RE READY THANKS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
PLEASE TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO FORTY
FORM BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA M. P. H. REPRESENT
AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILDERS
ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND WORKING TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION PRESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOMES AS WE ALL KNOW
THE COST OF HOUSING IS CREATED
DESPERATE CRISIS FOR STATE
RESIDENTS AT THE GROUND LEVEL
MANY ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE
NONPROFITS HAVE STEPPED UP TO
BUILD HOUSING TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITY. TEMPUS
AS A POINT WE HAVE RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AND COUNTRY HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN HELPING US WITH
HOUSING SHORTAGE AS MUCH
PROPERTY HOLDERS FAITH BASED
INSTITUTIONS ARE IN A GOOD
POSITION TO FILL AN IMPORTANT
GAP ESPECIALLY THE TIME WHEN
LAND FOR HOUSING COMES AT A
PREMIUM PRICE HOWEVER THESE
COMMUNITIES OFTEN FACE
ROADBLOCKS AND ONE SUCH
ROADBLOCK IS A LEGAL
INTERPRETATION THAT ROUTE THE
REDUCED ARKING REQUIREMENTS
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE ONLY APPLY TO
EXISTING RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS
AND NOT TO NEW ONES AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT
WE APPLY THESE COMMONSENSE
PARKING PRINCIPLES EQUALLY SET
NEW FAITH COMMUNITIES CAN ALSO
OPEN THE DOORS CALIFORNIANS IN
NEED. THIS IS A SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT STEP THAT EMPOWERS OUR
RELIGIOUS COMMUNITY TO HELP US
MAKE REAL PROGRESS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION I'M HAPPY TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS
NEEDED. I THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR TEST. AT THIS TIME WE WILL
GO TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR THE BILL JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. WE'RE IN A WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. SHARON
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
MARCH DIVERSE THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO
SPEAKING FOR HOUSING CALIFORNIA
TODAY IN SUPPORT. MADISON FROM
CA IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
DURING PLAN A CAR BOMB ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BE IN SUPPORT- IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
LINE SO WE ARE GOING TO GO TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF WHICH
THERE ARE NONE ON FILE SO
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THEY DO SO AT THIS
TIME. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
SCRAMBLING UP THERE SO. WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. COMMENTS MAYBE A
MOTION AND SECOND. WE DO HAVE
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY GABRIEL
A SECOND BY WARD- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE MANAGER- OH I'M SORRY I
WAS JUST GONNA SAY I THINK I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ARE CHAIR I THINK IT'S A
FANTASTIC BELL- I KNOW
PARTICULARLY LA THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF FAITH COMMUNITIES THAT
WANT TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
THEY SEE IT- YOU KNOW PART OF
THE WAY THAT THEY EXPRESS THEIR
FAITH IN PART OF THEIR MISSION
IN THE WORLD IS TO HELP LIFT UP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND THERE'S
NO MORE TANGIBLE WAY TO DO IT
THAN TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS WAY
SO- I JUST APPLIED YOU FOR ME
FOR THE BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. THIS
WORKS GREAT WITNESS TESTIMONY-
THIS JUST SEEMS LIKE A- SENSE
BILL. THAT THAT'S PART OF THE
SOLUTION AND- HAS NO OPPOSITION
TO RESPECT. ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SAID. DOING
CALDERON. MOTION TO PASS. A
WICKS HI WEEKS ICE. ARE TO. HIGH
I. CARILLO KOREA I'D GIVE.
GABRIEL I KALRA. KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WORK.
FOR AND THE BILL IS OUT. JUST TO
NON CONTRA BILL FROM OKAY. OKAY
LET'S SEE- LET'S MOVE ON TO MAN
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBER IT'S NICE TO BE
BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE- AB
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE WILL
BREAK DOWN SILOS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING AND
MEDICARE PROGRAMS 45% OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESS NESS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FIFTY YEARS OF
AGE AND OLDER. MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE PROGRAMS SUCH AS PACE
RAIL W. THE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
HELP PEOPLE LIVE INDEPENDENTLY
IN HOUSING INSTEAD OF AN LICENSE
CARE SETTINGS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO CREATING SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR THESE POPULATIONS IS
LACK OF FUNDING. AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES. IN THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM TO DEVELOPMENTS
THAT SET ASIDE A PERCENTAGE OF
UNITS FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS RECEIVING SPECIFIED
MEDICAL SERVICES. THIS BILL WILL
INCENTIVIZE CREATION OF HOUSING
THAT WILL HELP SENIORS EXIT
HOMELESSNESS ENABLE THEM TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY WITH SUPPORT
RATHER THAN A LICENSE SETTING.
WITH ME TODAY AND SUPPORT IS
TRICIA LEVINE FROM WAKELAND
HOUSING. AND MAYBE OTHERS YES
THE SHERIN HERE TO THANK YOU YOU
MAY BEGIN. AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TRICIA TASKER LEVINE AND
I WORK AS A DIRECTOR OF
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR WAKELAND
HOUSING AND DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. A LEADING NONPROFIT
DEVELOPER OF AFFORDABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. WAKELIN HAS
THREE DEVELOPMENTS PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
COMPREHENSIVE PAY SERVICES- A
SORRY EXCUSE ME- SO WE'VE
DEVELOPED- MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED AFFORDABLE HOMES AT
FIFTY THREE PROPERTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. WAKELIN
IS A LEADER IN DEVELOPING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR UN HOUSED
OLDER ADULTS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE PAYS PROGRAM PROGRAM OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
WE HAVE THREE DEVELOPMENTS
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
COMPREHENSIVE PAYS SERVICES TO
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED FORMALLY ON
HOUSED MEDICALLY FRAIL OLDER
ADULTS. ARE WARD WINNING
TALMADGE GATEWAY PROJECT OPEN IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I WAS THE
FIRST PROJECT IN SAN DIEGO
DEDICATED SOLELY TO HOUSING
HOMELESS FRAIL OLDER ADULTS. IN
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WE
OPENED TO OTHER SUPPORT OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN SAN
DIEGO DEDICATED TO ON HOUSED
OLDER ADULTS. THE PACE SERVICES
OFFERED ONSITE AND OFFSITE
PROVIDE THE RESIDENTS WITH
SERVICES THAT ALLOW THEM TO
REMAIN INDEPENDENT AND AGE IN
PLACE. THE PAY SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED. BY MEDIC COW AND COST
THE PROJECT NOTHING THIS IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF THE HOUSING AND
HEALTH PARTNERSHIP THAT BENEFITS
RESIDENTS HOUSING OPERATORS AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE BELIEVE SO
STRONGLY IN THIS MODEL THAT WE
ARE DEVELOPING FOR SIMILAR
PROJECTS IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND SEVERAL MORE
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO COUNTY
LEVERAGING MEDIC HOW FUNDED PACE
TO PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES. TO OUR TENANTS THESE
ARE SERVICES THAT ARE NOT
TYPICALLY PROVIDED IN MOST
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
THESE PROJECTS ARE SEEN AS A
NATIONAL MODEL AND HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED AT THE NATIONAL AND
STATE LEVEL FOR THE INNOVATIVE
COMBINATION OF PACE WITH
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. DESPITE OUR
SUCCESSES BARRIER STILL IN. CAL
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING MEDIC HOW
FUNDED PROVIDERS INCLUDING PACE
PROVIDERS OFTEN DO NOT HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH DEVELOPERS
THAT CREATE INDEPENDENT HOUSING
. HOUSING AND MEDICARE PROGRAMS
OR SIDELOAD WHICH PUTS THE
BURDEN ON THE CLIENTS TO
NAVIGATE THESE PROGRAMS
SEPARATELY. LASTLY MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING PAYS OFTEN
EXCLUDE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FROM PROGRAMS DUE
TO FEDERAL RULES REQUIRING THAT
THEY RECEIVE SERVICES AND HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
WHAT STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE WHICH WOULD
RESOLVE THESE BARRIERS BY
OFFERING DEVELOPERS INCENTIVES
TO CREATE A SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THE BILL WILL
PROMOTE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
DEVELOPERS AND MEDICAL PROVIDERS
BY OFFERING INCENTIVES AND
ALIGNING PROGRAM ELIGIBLE.
ELIGIBILITY I URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
SECOND WITNESS. A GOOD MORNING
THIS IS CHERYL I'M SHARING
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
SPONSORING THE BILL WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THEY YOU AND- AND OTHERS IN THE
ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
FOR MR MAN SPILLED AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE NAMED. VANESSA
CANNOT OF CAL PACE THE STATE
WHERE ASSOCIATE. WHO PAYS
PROGRAMS HERE IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH MARQUESS REPRESENTING
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. AND MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AND ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA TODAY IN
SUPPORT. AMBER MEDICINE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY FOLKS IN THE
ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
ON THE BILL. MISTER MAN CHECK
IT'S A GOLD STAR TODAY- BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. MR WARD
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL HAPPY
THAT SAN DIEGANS RECORDS. SOME
OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN
PIONEERING DOWN HERE I AM REALLY
EXCITED THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE
ABLE OPEN UP MORE DOORS
STATEWIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. WILL YOU
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR WAS STRICTLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN
THE SPACE I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
COMMITTED THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME I'D LOVE TO BE ADDED ON AS
A CO AUTHOR I MEAN THIS IS VERY
GOOD POLICY SO APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK. AND WITH THAT WE CAN TAKE
THE ROLE. WE NEED A SECOND. WELL
THERE YOU GO. THE MOTION IS TO
BE A COME APPROACH WICKS FIVE
WEEKS I SAY. CARILLO CARILLO I
GABRIELLE GABRIEL I CALL. KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA. COKE'S I TOWARD
WHAT I. AND THE BILLS OUT OF THE
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE MAN
MEMBERS. OKAY NOW WE ARE FOR
MISS GRACE. ARE MISTER IS. TO
TEST BRING THEIR BILLS. NO WE-
WERE SO CLOSE TEAM. I. THE
PHILADELPHIA MEDIA. THE INTEX
TECH'S GRAYSON BUSINESS THERE
MISTER. HERE. BAKERSFIELD THIS.
OKAY TEXAS A I DREAM. YOU KNOW
AND.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE RECALL WE
NEED.
RIGHT NOW ALL. SHE SAID WITH THE
MOMENT. HEARING I DO I HAVE TO
SAY THE WE NEED TO DO. THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON. MOVE
THE BELL THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON. EXPEDITE. YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
WITH THAT- MOTION AND SECOND I
WILL. BE BRIEF. I DO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS THE
CHAIR FOR YOUR WORK AND HELP ON
THIS BILL AND I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE HOUSING
COST REDUCTION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
IT'S AN INCENTIVE- TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REDUCE ORDER
FOR LOCAL IMPACT FEES FOR
QUALIFIED HOUSING PROJECTS. AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX PROVIDES
TO VOLUNTARY OPTIONS FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FIRST AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH 50% OF
THE VALUE OF THE OF THE FEE
REDUCTION GRANTED TO AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
SECONDLY IT ALSO ALLOWS
JURISDICTIONS TO DEFERRED FEES
UNTIL THE HOUSING PROJECT IS
CONVERTED TO PERMANENT FINANCING
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
BECAUSE IT IT DOES INCLUDE
INTEREST TO BE CHARGED WITH THE
STATE WILL BACK FILL THAT
INTEREST AFFECTIVELY PROVIDING
DEVELOPERS WITH A ZERO INTEREST
LOAN. ENSURING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE MADE WHOLE IN
OTHER WORDS THE DEVELOPER WILL
HAVE TO FINANCE THE IMPACT FEES-
WHICH HELPS BRING DOWN COSTS AND
WITH THE STATE PICKING UP THE
INTEREST SIDE OF IT KEEPS THE
COST AT A MINIMUM FOR THE STATE
IT MAKES THE PROJECT- PENCIL OUT
FOR THE DEVELOPER EVERYBODY WINS
THIS IS A WIN WIN WIN WIN FOR
THE DEVELOPER WHEN FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION AS A WIN FOR THE
RENTER OR THE- NEW HOMEOWNER OF
THAT PARTICULAR PROPERTY WITH
THAT I DO HAVE WITNESSES THAT
CAN SELF INCIDENTS. RIGHT MARKET
DRIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND EVEN
THOUGH THIS BILL CREATES A NEW
PROGRAM IT ACTUALLY SAVES THE
STATE MONEY- THE STATE THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT HOUSING RIGHT NOW
IS PAYING THESE DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES WITH LARGER LOANS
THROUGH ITSMULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM AND IF WE CAN GET LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SHARE IN REDUCING
THE COST OF THOSE FEES WHILE AND
THE STATE JUST REIMBURSING THIS
WELCOME HALF OF THAT AMOUNT THE
STATE CAN ACTUALLY HAS MORE
FUNDS IN ITS MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM TO BUILD
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
THIS ACTUALLY IS A WIN WIN WIN.
AS YOU MEMBER SAID. HI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WILL BE BRIEF AIR
INDIA'S THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OR IN CALIFORNIA WE
THINK THIS WILL BE EXTREMELY
IMPACTFUL ESPECIALLY THE HIGH
COST AREAS OF OUR STATE AND
HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE OTHER FOLKS IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU SEE ON INSTITUTING THE HALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARQUESS REPRESENTING
LEADING H. CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. VENTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONAHAN
THE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL NOT SURE WERE IN
SUPPORT BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. GREAT
MBER MEDICINE FROM A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU AND WILL NOT GO TO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FOR MR GRAYSON'S
BILL AB TWENTY SIX OKAY ANY
FOLKS IN THE ROOM WAS TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL. OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MISS
QUIRK-SILVA. SO I FEEL LIKE A
CHEERLEADER TODAY WHERE I WANT
TO SAY YES BECAUSE WE NEED THIS
TYPE OF LEGISLATION IT'S A WIN
WIN AND I'D LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERED AS A JOINT AUTHORS-
BUT EVEN MORE- IT JUST.
CONTINUES TO MOVE THAT GOAL
FORWARD WHICH IS LET'S CREATE
HOUSING HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIANS. MR GABRIEL YEAH I
WANT TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY- I ALTHOUGH I
THINK TECHNICALLY IT'S A WIN WIN
WIN WIN SO THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON FOR- FOR SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
YOU HAVE BEEN- A REAL LEADER IN
THE ASSEMBLY ON THESE ISSUES I
KNOW- PARTICULARLY IMPACT FEES
AND LOWERING THE COST OF
PRODUCING HOUSING. MAKING IT
MORE AFFORDABLE- SO I THINK THIS
IS A FANTASTIC FELT EXACTLY THE
KIND OF POLICY I THINK WE NEED
TO BE CONSIDERING AND I'D ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND I THINK THAT SINCE I'M
ON THE COMMITTEE AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. MISTER GRAYSON
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER. THANK
YOU I ALSO WANT TO ADD ON- THE
ACCOLADES- AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ON THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
CREATIVE IT'S NECESSARY. AS
WE'VE ALL SAID IT'S A WIN WIN
WIN- IT WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED
ON IT AS A CO AUTHOR AT WHATEVER
LEVEL YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH.
AND ALSO JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
HARD WORK IN THIS SPACE YOU'VE
BEEN A GREAT PARTNER AND LEADER
IN HOUSING AND- IT'S AN HONOR TO
WORK ALONGSIDE YOU SO WITH THAT-
WITH EMOTION. YES WE CAN. YES
OKAY GREAT- THE MOTION TO PASS
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WICKS I'VE
WICKS I SEYARTO CORREO GABRIEL
GABRIEL I KALRA KILEY
QUIRK-SILVA QUIRK-SILVA I WARNED
. WARD I. THAT DOUBLES ON CALL
THANK YOU AND OUR LAST BILL.
MISTER NAZARIAN THANK YOU. MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU AND THANKS
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- ONE OF THE FIRST START
OFF BY SAYING THANK YOU TO THE%
CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR THE
THOROUGH AND THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALSO-
KNOWING YOUR ETHICS AND YOUR
DESIRE TO SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR I
INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME AS A JOINT
AUTHORS WHEN YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE ON THIS BILL- AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN CREATES
THE HOUSING STABILIZATION TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
AMONG OLDER ADULTS. AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES WE KNOW ALL
TOO WELL OLDER LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD THEIR RENT AND ARE FACING
A SURGE OF HOMELESSNESS SO THIS
LEGISLATION FURTHERS THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING GOAL OF
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
OLDER ADULTS- JUST TO. JUST TO
HELP GRASP THE NEED AND I WILL
BRIEFLY MAKE THIS COMMENT AND
THEN TURN IT OVER TO. MY STAR
WITNESSES OF FAIR MARKET RENT IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HARD TO
ESTIMATE OF MEDIAN RENTS FOR
LOOK AT NON LUXURY APARTMENT.
INCREASED BY A HUNDRED AND 16%
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FROM SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN DOLLARS IN
TWO THOUSAND TO SIXTEEN HUNDRED
FOURTEEN DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY- MEANWHILE. SSI INCREASED
FROM SEVEN HUNDRED TWELVE
DOLLARS A MONTH IN TWENTY
TWENTY. TWO THE ONLY A THOUSAND
FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO GIVEN THOSE
DISPARITIES. IT'S EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING FOR OLDER ADULTS ON
FIXED INCOME TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN AND HOLD THEIR- RENTAL
PROPERTIES SO WITH THAT WITH ME
TODAY. REPRESENTING A PORTION OF
THE COALITION BEHIND AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN R. ERIN
CARUTHERS WITH THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND PATTY. PRUNE HUBER WITH THE
JUSTICE IN AGING. THANK YOU HE
MAY BEGIN IN TWO MINUTES EACH
PLACE THANK YOU- CHAIR WICKS IN
THE COMMITTEE- WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN. WE KNOW THAT OLDER LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ARE BEING
OUT PRICED FROM THEIR RENTAL
UNITS EIGHT INTEN EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME OLDER RENTERS. ARE PAYING
MORE THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME
RENT FOR RENT. AND CALIFORNIANS
AGE FIFTY AND OLDER ARE THE
FASTEST GROWING AGE GROUP
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS NOW
COMPRISING 45% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL WITH STARK
RACIAL DISPARITIES- BLACK ADULTS
ARE FIVE TIMES AT GREATER RISK
OF EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THAN WHITE CALIFORNIANS. THIS
BILL PROVIDES- A KEY GOAL OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING TO PREVENT
AN AND OLDER ADULT HOMELESSNESS.
AND IT WOULD ALSO- ADDRESS
ANOTHER AT RISK POPULATION
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES.
ESTABLISHING A MULTI YEAR RENT
STABILIZATION FUND TO PROVIDE
RENTAL SUBSIDIES WHO ARE AT
IMMINENT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS OR
CURRENTLY ON HOUSING AND IT
WOULD ENABLE TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND RENTER HOUSEHOLDS
ANNUALLY. TO ACCESS OR KEEP
THEIR HOUSING- IT IS SO
IMPORTANT THE WORK THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DOING TO
PROVIDE PIPELINE FOR NEW HOUSING
BUT UNLESS WE STAUNCH. THE THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE AILING A
LEAKY SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND HOPE WE CAN.
WORK TOGETHER ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ERIN CARUTHERS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES OF PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
SERVED IN OUR STATE THROUGH A
MEDICAID WAIVER CALL HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. AND
THE PURPOSE OF THAT WAIVER IS AS
THE NAME DESCRIBES TO SET THE
PEOPLE CAN BE SERVED IN THEIR
HOMES OR IN THE COMMUNITIES IN
OUT OF INSTITUTIONS THIS IS A
WONDERFUL PROGRESS REMOVING
PEOPLE OUT OF INSTITUTIONS- BUT
ONE PIECE ABOUT IT IS THAT THE-
DOLLARS ONLY SERVE. SUPPORT
SERVICES- THEY DON'T SERVE
ACTUAL FUNDING FOR HOUSING- SO
WELL THERE IS A PUSH BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR PEOPLE TO
BE SERVED IN THE COMMUNITIES-
THERE ISN'T FUNDING FOR THE
HOUSING TO GO WITH IT THIS BILL
WILL GET A LONG WAYS IN CLOSING
THAT GAP. THE WHAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING IS THAT 68% OF
ADULTS OF REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS- ARE LIVING AT HOME WITH
AGING CARE GIVERS SO WE SEE THIS
INTERSECTION BETWEEN
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
AGING- AND THERE'S A QUESTION
THAT MANY FAMILIES US THAT ASK
THEMSELVES WHICH IS WHAT IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO ME- WHAT
pSOMETHING HAPPENS TO ME. SO THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE AN ANSWER TO
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU AND- IF THERE ARE FOLKS IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ON THEIR SUPPORT PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION. GOOD
MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. VENTURA MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ONBEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IS HOUSING
IS A HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
NECESSARY BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. SYNDICATES THE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. AMBER
ADDISON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. PROVOCA MARQUESS ON BEHALF OF
CO SPONSOR LEADING H. CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS ASK A TIMELESSLY
SENIOR COMMUNITIES LIFE STOPS
WHEN NORA HOUSING RETIREMENT
HOUSING FOUNDATION SANTA CLARA
METHODIST RETIREMENT FOUNDATION
ST PAUL SENIOR SERVICES TELUGU
AND THE VALLEY VILLAGE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
VANESSA KICKING ON BEHALF OF CAL
PACE IN SUPPORT. JUST BECAUSE I
GUESS ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN. SEEING NONE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I LOOKS LIKE A FANTASTIC BELTS
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW
HE'S BEEN A LEADER IN A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES ON BOTH
HOMELESSNESS ON TAKING CARE OF
OUR- OUR AGING POPULATION AND I
JUST COULD NOT AGREE MORE WITH
OUR WITNESS THAT- LOOKING TO
PREVENT. PEOPLE FROM SLIPPING
INTO HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS I THINK
WE HAVE NOT PUT ENOUGH ATTENTION
AND RESOURCES INTO SO- HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL TODAY AND I THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD YOU WANT
TO SAY ANYTHING WITH NO OKAY I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT LAST
FOREVER WELL I AM SURE THE
SENTIMENT FROM MY COLLEAGUE MR
GABRIEL I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK FRAZIER THE TESTIMONY OF
THE WITNESSES HERE- AS YOU ALL
KNOW SENIORS ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING SEGMENT OF HOMELESSNESS
I VIEW THIS IS A MORAL
OBLIGATION TO REALLY ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE
THAT WE EVEN ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN I WOULD BE HONORED TO BE-
ADDED AS A JOINT AUTHOR I'M
WILLING TO WORK ALONGSIDE YOU TO
PASS THIS BILL SO WITH THAT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE. WICKS I WEEKS I'D SAY
ARCHER. CORREO GABRIEL. GABRIEL
I KALRA. KILEY QUIRK-SILVA. WARD
WHAT I. THE BILL'S ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SHE.
I DON'T KNOW REMARKABLE TIME.
SENATE STAFFER YEAH. THE LONG
TERM. THERE'S.
GALLAGHER WE WILL- WE'LL START
FROM THE BEGINNING TO DO ADD ONS
. SIERRA WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OKAY ALL RIGHT-
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN- DEPRESSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN EDUCATION
KALRA KALRA I. THE BILL IS OUT-
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT- TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
EDUCATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. I BILLS OUT. ITEM NUMBER THREE
THAT'S A CONSENT ITEM MAY BE TWO
OR SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOLERA TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS. I. I AM NUMBER
OF FOUR OF TWO ZERO SIX THREE-
DO PASSED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. I FELT WITH ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY FIFTY TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
JUDICIARY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
. KALRA AT THE CELL- I ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
SIX- DEPRESSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEYARTO. AT NOT
A PROBLEM OF THE GRACE OF THE-
I'VE MET I. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA SUPERAMERICA I ESTIMATE
CARILLO ABSENCE B. FIVE TWO ZERO
THREE. GOOD SIX OUT. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN- AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN-
DEPRESSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. I AM VERY. THIRTY
SIX SIX THE ONE THAT BILLS OUT-
I AM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE- THE BEST TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. KALRA I.
FIFTY TWO FIFTY FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN ZERO- ITEM
NUMBER NINE- AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THIS
IS TO PASS THREE PASSED HIS.
RIGHT R. I. P. SEVEN ZERO THE
ITEM NUMBER TEN- AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE OUR DEFENSE TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIERRA RIGHT. HI
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER SARAH I
SIMMER KALRA KALRA I. SEVEN ZERO
AND- WE HAVE- I AM NUMBER ELEVEN
A. B. TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN DO
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
AGING AND LONG TERM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- SERICA NO. NO SEVEN
MEMBER CARILLO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA KALRA I. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. SO THIS IS WE NEED
ONE MORE VOTE FOR THEM CORRECT.
IT WOULD. OKAY WILL IT BELIEVE
THAT OPEN. BECAUSE I AM A BILL-
THE BERMAN BILL. NO THAT WAS.
FIFTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THE YEAH
I ALREADY DID YEAH. THERE ANY
EARLY ONES I MISSED FROM BEING
IN NYC NO OKAY SO WE'RE GOOD YES
. I HAVE 2% ELEVEN ORCHARDS ON
THE WAY BACK RIGHT NOW- CAT ON
THINK WE CAN CLOSE DOWN- YEAH
ACTUALLY I THINK.
ONE MOMENT LET ME DOUBLE CHECK
IN NUMBER. SIX THIS IS THE ITEM
OUR NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN- DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON AGING AND
LONG TERM- SEPTEMBER CARILLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
QUIRK-SILVA I. SEVEN FIVE TWO
ONE BY THAT BILLS OUT FIVE TO
ONE. ALL RIGHTS ALL THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND DURING THE MEETING THANK YOU.